non
pour les étudiants à l'ostal liste au
tournoi amenant à brignac a dans
l'équipe
au tournant crayon titre auxerre
mm
beautiful
motif
[Musique]
vadimir poutine
monsieur le président de la fédération
de russie vladimir poutine
monsieur le cheikh tamim ben hamad al
thani émir du qatar
monsieur sebastian kurz consulaires
comme chancelier d'autriche stanislas
nathanson
[Applaudissements]
mesdames messieurs bonjour bienvenue au
forum économique international de saint
pétersbourg c'est la plus grande réunion
de cette ampleur depuis la pandémie et
qui se déroule sous cette forme hybride
et ça fait plaisir de se revoir
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de questions
à discuter qui se sont accumulés et je
pense que la discussion d'aujourd'hui
sera ouverte franche et intéressantes
comme toujours pour lors de ces
rencontres nous avons d'abord des
discussions des dirigeants et monsieur
vladimir poutine à vous la parole
son excellence monsieur les miens
monsieur le chancelier fédéral
mesdames messieurs chers amis je suis
heureux de vous accueillir pour le 24e
forum économique international de saint
pétersbourg
je règle les équipements vous savez que
depuis le début de l'année dernière en
raison de l'épidémie de corona virus un
certain nombre de plateformes de
discussion ont été annulés ou se sont
déroulés à distance et nous sommes
heureux de pouvoir après cette
interruption forcée si longue de pouvoir
ici organisé en russie
cette grande rencontre d'affaires qui
nous permet de réunir des représentants
des milieux d'affaires à l'international
et de pouvoir discuter et aussi de ne
voir directement et bien entendu nous
avons cherché à faire tout ce qui était
possible pour assurer la sécurité des
participants
en pleine adéquation avec les règles
sanitaires et ce forum qui est si
représentatif et qui se tient
aujourd'hui c'est donc un signe très
positif ça veut dire que les liens de
partenariat
les échanges entre les experts les
milieux d'affaires reprennent un aspect
naturel est habituel c'est tendance
positive s'observe aussi dans l'économie
internationale malgré la profondeur de
la récession de l'année dernière qui
avait été la plus grande crise depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale
nous pouvons avec certitude dire
aujourd'hui que nous reprenons un rythme
de vie normal et nous attendions que
cette année l'augmentation du pib
internet sera augmente et sera à peu
près celle des années 70 avec 6% de
croissance prévu et donc des discus des
décisions absolument exceptionnelles ont
été prises et la pratique a montré que
ce n'est que les les seules mesures
traditionnelles de résolution des crises
se sont montrés insuffisante
donc il ya une politique budgétaire qui
est importante notamment dans les pays
émergents et qui pour la première fois
on a vu qu'elle était soutenue par les
banques centrales
évidemment les économies majeures avec
leurs instruments de soutien à
l'activité
on fait beaucoup plus évidemment les
chiffres parlent d'eux même si dans les
pays industrialisés on a eu par exemple
10% de du pib qui a souffert 5% dans les
pays moins développés
mais les décisions les solutions aux
crises qui sont financés évidemment
c'est bien c'est positif mais
malheureusement il ya aussi des aspects
négatifs et donc on constate des
disparités
ici dans le développement entre les pays
et donc il ya ce déséquilibre dans les
niveaux de vie tant au sein des pays que
entre les pays cela suscite des risques
particuliers pour le monde qui est
interconnecté aujourd'hui et j'en avais
parlé lors du forum de davos aussi est
temps que nous assurons pas un accès au
vaccin contre le corps en avait partout
sur tous les continents
il y aura toujours un risque qui se
maintiendra 2
vague d'infections différentes dans
cette menace qui s'est présenté a touché
toute la fin toute la planète or ce que
nous voyons aujourd'hui d'après le
aujourd'hui on voit 16% de la population
qui est seulement qu'il n'a accès qu'à
un vaccin sûr aujourd'hui on a 10% de la
population ont été vaccinés complètement
vous qui ont au moins reçu le premier
élément de vaccination alors que on a
des centaines de millions de personnes
qui sont tout à fait loigné de cet accès
au vaccin tout simplement soit par
manque structurel soit par manque tout
simplement de moyens financiers et
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de solution
satisfaisant donc on l'a on lave son
linge sale en famille
aujourd'hui et c'est ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui au niveau mondial autour de
la pandémie
ça veut dire que une partie de la
population ne bénéficie pas des aides
alors que des interdictions motivé pour
des motifs politiques sont utilisées et
qui mettent en doute la fiabilité de ces
vaccins donc certains on a vu on a
constaté que certains pays cherchent à
protéger leurs citoyens en exclusivité
comme vous l'avez vu la russie a mise au
point quatre vaccins le spoutnik v a
déjà été enregistré déjà dans 66 pays
dans le monde
c'est à dire que il est accessible déjà
à 3 milliards 200 millions d'habitants
non seulement nous avons créé une
technologie
rapidement mais nous avons aider nos
partenaires à l'international pour
qu'ils puissent développer des sites sur
leur pays est aujourd'hui à part la
russie personne ne l'a proposé ça veut
dire que chaque citoyen majeur en russie
a la possibilité de se faire vacciner de
façon volontaire gratuitement et de
façon et facilement et je demande encore
une fois à mes concitoyens de bénéficier
de cette opportunité d'en profiter
puisque le vaccin russe a été reconnu
comme le plus fiable et le plus efficace
à plus de 96% et aujourd'hui on n'a
aucun cas létale après l'administration
du vaccin moi même je me suis fait
vacciner
donc il ya une protection qui est bonne
contre les effets secondaires et je
demande aux autorités régionales de
vérifier le l'application des normes
sanitaires notamment lorsqu'il ya une
immigration de travail qui vient dans le
secteur du btp et notre secteur
pharmaceutique est tout à fait prêt à
poursuivre ses efforts a travaillé dans
cette ligne et faire en sorte que des
citoyens d'autres pays puissent venir
aussi se faire vacciner
compte tenu des possibilités offertes
par ce vaccin je sais qu on a ici donc
on a une diffusion très large et on a
des représentants des milieux d'affaires
par exemple de pays occidentaux et
d'autres pays qui viennent en russie
pour se faire vacciner et à cet égard je
demande au gouvernement d'étudier toutes
ces questions sous tous ses aspects
avant la fin du mois un premier plan sur
le plan de la sécurité dans pour que les
étrangers puissent se faire vacciner à
titre payant
ici dans notre pays
donc dans cette période de
réhabilitation de rétablissement après
la crise nous avons besoin ici d'assurer
une croissance de manifester les
opportunités qui se proposent être
concurrentiels sur le plan technologique
sur le plan scientifique et en même
temps maintenir les liens
d'investissement entre les pays et
justement c'est ce côté multivectorielle
et qui est un facteur de reprise de
l'économie au niveau international et
nous sommes reconnaissants tous nos
partenaires qui ont participé à cet
effort et qui continue dans la condition
de pandémie et malgré les difficultés de
politique internationale continue à
travailler avec nous à ce propos je suis
heureux de vous annoncer que justement
aujourd'hui il y à 12h30
ça a été la pose du gazoduc north stream
2 vient d'être achevée donc c'est un
travail qui tue c'est à dire toute la
tranche maritime de la construction a
été fait
ça veut dire que aujourd'hui la conduite
a été posée dans les deux sens et de
même cette semaine là la partie qui
relie à la station a été
rollier est pourquoi je dis ça parce que
c'est le système le plus eu
le plus avancé du point de vue
technologique et cet itinéraire va
relier le système le système national en
russie et l'allemagne
donc tout cela fait en sorte que nous
avons des approvisionnements sûrs
fiables vers l'europe
donc ce projet économiquement
particulièrement efficace qui correspond
aux normes les plus élevées du point de
vue technique et économique et réaliser
et nous avons bien l'intention de
poursuivre cette collobert collaboration
avec nos partenaires européens et je
pense que la logique de l'avantagent
mutuelle sera confronté probablement à
des barrières artificielles politique et
je voudrais dire quelques mots à propos
des priorités de notre agenda intérieur
grâce aux mesures prises en temps
opportun la russie à peu réussi à
préserver
en gros la situation économique avec le
maintien de l'emploi
ça c'est important oui il y a des
problèmes oui il ya une augmentation du
chômage
nous le savons nous avons très bien pu
constater ces problèmes nous cachons
rien mais nous aurions pu avoir une
catastrophe mais nous avons pu l'éviter
et nous avons pu maintenir un pouvoir
d'achat correct nous avons travaillé au
niveau des régions avec les entreprises
nous avons adopté des mesures ciblées
pour la population la difficulté dans le
domaine de l'emploi se maintient j'en
parlerai encore mais nous comprenons que
ces défis
qui se posent notamment le chômage chez
les jeunes
le déséquilibre des marchés régionaux
tout cela nous le comprenons bien et je
ne le comprenons bien qu'il faut pas non
plus faire incomber tous ces problèmes à
la pandémie
il y a des problèmes structurels qui se
maintiennent dans notre économie et donc
il faut poursuivre les efforts que nous
faisons et notamment dans les entités de
la fédération où le taux de chômage
reste élevé et les mesures que nous
adoptons nous devons doivent être
adaptées à chaque région à l'échelle de
l'ensemble du pays
je nous allons lancer des programmes de
soutien à l'emploi des jeunes à
l'entrepreneuriat je suis bien conscient
que les réponses systémiques de maintien
du pouvoir d'achat de croissance
économique tout cela de nouvelles
opportunités d'emploi tout cela c'est
important mais l'histoire mondiale
montre que après les grandes
perturbations les redressement
économique ont toujours été liés à des
infrastructures a des parts dans à des
investissements dans les infrastructures
et à la formation du personnel ça c'est
important et je remercie les entités de
la fédération qui ont su dans ces
conditions difficiles à se concentrer de
façon particulièrement aiguë a effectué
les pauses nécessaires sur certains
points mais à faire en sorte que le
climat d'affaires soit maintenu et ces
régions ont su faire venir des
investisseurs
et ça c'est une appréciation positive
que nous donne que nous donnons et
malgré les parmi les dix premiers il ya
la région de novgorod mach cary grant et
monde jusque samara sakhaline
tcheliabinsk par exemple nous avons
et nous allons continuer continuer à
travailler dans cette direction et je
prie les gouverneurs de régions de
renforcer leurs efforts et de placer
l'accent en particulier sur les sur les
entités qui elles ont besoin de plus
d'un vertige d'investissement il faut
bien sûr travailler mieux avec les
investisseurs c'est très concret d'ici
2020 4 partout dans chaque région de la
russie
il faut garantir pour les entreprises
pour les entreprises privées des
conditions transparentes et prévisible
qui serait confortable pour ces
entreprises de quoi s'agit-il
chaque région doit avoir des priorités
de son développement et cette
information doit être ouverte pour les
entreprises comme le secteur d'urbanisme
tout ce qui concernait les
infrastructures d'ingénierie les
communications et de cette manière les
entreprises seraient à même de
construire des nouveaux sites
il faut éliminer les maillons superflu
la bureaucratie et il faut le faire très
rapidement dans des secteurs très
sensibles
il s'agit par exemple des réseaux de
communication l'obtention des
autorisations autorisations de
construction nous supprimons bien sûr
des barrières bureaucratiques
depuis le 1er septembre environ 4000
normes seront supprimés et suite à cette
décision puisque il y avait des milliers
de 10000 normes
il ya eu des barrières bien sûr mais là
il y a un potentiel pour simplifier les
choses bien sûr c'est
un travail méticuleux mais qui a été
fait durant deux ans on va continuer
dans cette voie et nous allons garantir
la sécurité dans le secteur du bâtiment
je porte l'attention des régions ainsi
que des clients au niveau régional et
fédéral
je porte l'attention aux chefs
d'entreprise est tout les documents qui
font partie de l'autorisation de
construire seront conformes à ces
nouvelles normes et aussi à des
nouvelles technologies les technologies
hautement écologique des matériaux de
construction est en général chaque
région doit avoir un algorithme
transparent très concrets pour ne pas
perdre le temps pour avoir un coût
minime hama pour ouvrir des nouvelles
entreprises et de nouveaux sites
industriels
encore une fois je souligne qu'il faut
travailler ensemble le gouvernement et
les régions et le bloc économique de
notre gouvernement sera évaluée et suite
à une dynamique de cette activité là où
il ya des problèmes il faut les résoudre
s'il vous plaît ne faites pas l'air que
cela ne vous concerne pas non cela
concerne tout le monde et il faut
travailler avec les régions qui en ont
besoin et je répète nous n'avons pas
besoin de régions qui sont en marche de
la croissance et économique puisque le
potentiel d'investissement existent dans
chaque région
donc il faut réaliser ce potentiel dans
les intérêts des citoyens des familles
russes
un nouveaux outils c'est le programme
des crédits d'investissement les régions
auront la possibilité d'attirer des
investissements à des taux d'intérêt
assez intéressant on va en parler on a
déjà parlé de ce programme
et d'ici deux ans le volume
d'investissement va constituer environ
500 millions de roubles et je redis je
demande les responsables des régions d'y
faire attention
notre priorité c'est de créer un milieu
confortable pour les gens dans des
régions dans des villes dans l'économie
autour de l'homme
ça c'est le moteur est très important de
la croissance économique à la base des
meilleures normes internationales et du
classement de du climat d'investissement
notre agence a mis au point le
classement du niveau de vie des régions
ça c'est un indicateur très humble et
matic et je voudrais parler un peu de
résultats de ce classement on
s'attendait que les leaders c'est moscou
la région de tioumen y tatarstan cannes
theman6 la ville de saint pétersbourg se
sont au centre de l'activité économique
où nous avons beaucoup d'investissements
dans les infrastructures le niveau de
vie ce qui est important est important
c'est que beaucoup plus de régions
russes sont conformes à ces normes
internationales et affiche une dynamique
très positive
par exemple dans l'éducation la
république de mordovie dents
le climat d'affaires co2 morty ou bien
la région de novgorod
ou bien la fidélité et des gens à à sa
propre nation c'est un indicateur
important
et là dessus on peut parler de la région
de kaliningrad de la ville de sébastopol
bien sûr ce classement de niveau de vie
nous permet d'évaluer la situation et
voir où sont les meilleures pratiques
ce classement est basé sur la vie et les
évolutions des gens des citoyens et bien
sûr pour les responsables ce retour nous
permet de construire toute notre
activité en se basant sur des sujets
sensibles parmi ces sujets bien sûr
c'est l'accessibilité de l'habitat je
sais que ici au forum et bien sûr dans
le pays
on parle beaucoup des avantages des
crédits hypothécaires
on parle du taux 6,5 pour cent c'est
très important et pour le moment plus
d'un demi million de gens honte reçu ces
crédits et nous avons attiré plus de
3000 milliards de roubles mais ce projet
expire le 1er juillet
e mais ce programme avait une nature
anti crise provisoire mais nous ne
voulons pas arrêter ce programme et il
faut prendre en compte le fait que le
crédit hypothécaire est très important
dans ce contexte pour résoudre le
problèmes d'habitat pour développer le
secteur de petits manques et le moteur
d'autres secteurs et je propose donc de
continuer dans toutes les régions
le développement de ce programme
jusqu'au 1er juillet de l'année
prochaine
mais bien sûr va relever un peu ce taux
d'intérêt et on va établir ce taux aux
niveaux 2 7%
mais ce taux serait unique pour toutes
les régions et les investissements au
niveau de 3 millions il faut rendre
accessible le crédit et petits caire
pour toutes les familles de quoi je
parle
nous avons déjà des mesures systémiques
c'est le crédit hypothécaire
depuis qu'ils aient l'année 2018 pour
les familles qui ont deux opus enfants
on va élargir ce programme et ce
programme sera concerné toutes les
familles qui ont les enfants qui ont les
enfants qui sont nés en après le 1er
juillet même avec un seul juillet on
peut obtenir ce crédit est petit coeur
pour le taux de 7% dans les conditions
de refinancement et le montant de ce
crédit pour moscou et saint pétersbourg
est la région de moscou et de leningrad
va s'élever 12 millions de roubles et 6
millions de roubles pour toutes les
autres entités fédérales se reconnaît
que nous espérons que l'amélioration du
niveau de vie et le développement de
l'infrastructure dans les régions sera
le moteur de notre activité économique
est un investissement privé et aussi va
ouvrir des opportunités pour les grandes
entreprises pour les entreprises et
petites et moyennes et il va ouvrir les
possibilités pour le milieu d'affaires
puisque la concurrence assez le moteur
du développement
et c'est le facteur pour freiner la
hausse des prix on a pris une décision
pour soutenir les pme et on a obtenu la
baisse de 15 à 20%
les cotisations d'assurance pour ces
entreprises et on va continuer dans
cette voie et aujourd'hui que je
voudrais vous parler de quelques mesures
de soutien d'abord je propose cette
année de lancer un mécanisme de crédit
un mécanisme nouveau pour les
entreprises c'est à dire une tutelle
exit de parapluies cette institution va
à être chargé des cautions pour être
chargé de couvrir les risques pour les
pme et cela va rendre les crédits plus
accessible et ce qui va permettre aux
entreprises d'avoir des moyens pour le
moyen de pour le montant de 600
milliards de roubles 1 et je sais que
les pme se plaignent de
et c'est cette commission bancaire qui
est assez élevé
nous avons élargi ce système de paiement
rapide qui leur permettent de faire des
paiements avec des taux plus intéressant
par exemple des transactions entre les
personnes physiques et les personnes
morales mais de toute façon c'est
outillés n'est pas très efficace et
n'est pas très utilisé et jusqu'au 1er
septembre de cette année nous allons
inclure dans ce programme
toutes les banques systémiques de notre
pays et les grandes banques vont le
faire très rapidement et d'ici le 1er
juillet et je propose pour la période
d'ici la fin d'année et je pense que
pour les gens qui en sont responsables
et le chef d'entreprise de moyenne
taille seront concernés et donc on va
aller lui rembourser cette commission
dans le cas où ils vont vendre des
services et des biens à des personnes
physiques et je répète que 2,7 vanier
manière le coût des services de paiement
rapide sera égal à zéro on va parler on
a discuté de cela avec les collègues
bien sûr là dessus il faut soutenir
cette initiative et je crois que c'est
très important
aujourd'hui les entreprises qui
travaillent qui bénéficie d'une
imposition simplifiée pourrait passer au
régime général en fonction du bénéfice
et du nombre de salariés cela signifie
que ce sera une charge supplémentaire
une charge fiscale supplémentaire pour
les entreprises et donc il faut trouver
d'autres solutions pour soulager les
entreprises de la pression cela concerne
par exemple les entreprises dans le
secteur de la restauration collective
et on peut lancer l'année prochaine je
propose de lancer l'année prochaine des
projets pilotes avec pour qu'ils
puissent passer d'un régime fiscal à un
autre de façon plus de 12 ou plus souple
c'est à dire que les entreprises seront
exonérées deux de leurs paiements de tva
si leurs bénéfices sont inférieurs à 2
milliards de roubles ça peut concerner
15 % et si par exemple si les entre le
nombre de salariés est inférieur à 1500
nous allons voir chers collègues
quels seront ces mesures pour
l'encouragement les entreprises et aussi
que les entreprises cessent de
travailler au noir que tout les tous les
tickets de caisse soit enregistré que le
les salaires soient payés officiellement
et non pas dans des enveloppes
je vous remercie je vois que nous
parlons de la même langue
c'est à dire de notre tête nous allons
faire tout ce qui est possible pour que
l'état remplisse ses obligations
j'ajoute aussi que nous sommes d'accord
sur l'exonération d'impôts pour les
entreprises qui utilisent le régime
d'imposition simplifié
nous avons discuté avec les
représentants du gouvernement et du
parlement
nous en avions parlé l'année dernière
mais depuis
la situation a peu évolué je vous prie
de simplifier et de bien travailler
cette procédure
je vous prie aussi de suivre les
activités de contrôle de concurrence là
on est en croissance économique
on voit que ces contrôles anti monopole
concerne absolument tous les tous les
secteurs avec comme plancher comme
valeur limite 400 millions et je propose
de l'augmenter à 800 millions de roubles
et dia un autre notre limite qu'on peut
établir ici c'est à dire que si le
montant d'une transaction ne dépasse pas
800 millions à ce moment là il n'est pas
nécessaire de la faire valider par l'
agence centrale de lutte contre le
monopole
tout cela fait que je propose
d'augmenter la part des biens et
services que les entités municipales
fédéral et ses puces acheté à 25 % au
minimum aux entreprises locales je nous
avons une discussion ici approfondie il
ya par exemple les entreprises qui
travaillent dans le cadre du 20e
anniversaire de la législation russe se
pose problème c'est les lois fédérales
223 44 et je comprends parfaitement
qu'il ya des types de produits que
l'industrie russe ne produit pas mais en
tout cas il ya quand même les limites
qu'on établit et que le gouvernement
doit élaborer
[Applaudissements]
en outre il faut réduire les délais de
30 à 15 jours ouvrables les délais de
livraison pour les entreprises parce que
c'est important pour tout ces pme et
aussi les associations à but non
lucratif
parce que ces sociétés ces structures et
je prie les et des services de l'état de
contrôler et d'être particulièrement
attentifs aux procédures d'achats de
biens pour l'état de faire en sorte qu
autant que possible ce soit des biens de
fabrication vous mesdames et messieurs
j'ai parlé aujourd'hui de la nécessité
de surmonter les difficultés sociales
après la pandémie mais je suis sur le
fait qu'il faut travailler en
coopération à l'international nous avons
des défis qui se posent aujourd'hui ce
sont des défis à long terme qui ne
doivent pas dépendre de disputes et de
différends politiques mais là il s'agit
de l'avenir de notre civilisation et de
quoi je parle et si je parle
principalement de l'agenda climatique
d'après les scientifiques les
conséquences de l'activité humaine
produisent chaque année 2000 milliards
de tonnes d'effet de serre et il ya des
discussions sur le fait qu'il faut
réduire tout cela et certains disent que
la russie n'est pas très intéressés à ce
à cela c'est complètement faux c'était
du délire total
c'est une extrapolé l'extrapolation de
ce qui était dit on nous a parlé de
d'érosion de de fonte de la merzlota et
tout ça et nous avons des villes
entières en arctique et nous sommes
particulièrement sensibles assez assez
assez problème nous soutenons la
convention cadre de l'onu sur la
protection de l'environnement et le le
pacte de paris et nous demandons parce
que tous les pays ont aujourd'hui cette
responsabilité celle qui est qui
concerne la vie des générations à venir
la neutralité carbone ne doit pas se
faire sous des prétextes politiques qui
sont utilisés pour gérer les flux
économiques et commerciaux et qui
servent sous le couvert de progression
technologique de dissuasion contre
certains pays nous voyons dans cette
évolution du climat
il y a les projets qui ont été
développés dans la russie et je pense
que certains d'entre eux vont jouer leur
rôle dans le développement international
dans les efforts internationaux
le volume dans les 30 ans à venir des
gaz à effet de serre en russie d'où doit
être inférieur à celui à ceux qui sont
émis en europe donc pour l'année
prochaine nous allons et élaborer un
nouveau plan et nous consacrerons une
réunion spéciale là dessus alors quelles
sont les orientations sur lesquels nous
allons travailler
donc la réduction des rejets dans l'air
nous avons déjà dit que l'énergie russe
a fortement réduit la part carbone dans
sa production d'énergie nous avons
développé les énergies renouvelables et
nous avons des réserves de gaz
considérable parmi les plus
considérables dans le monde
certes c'est un hydrocarbure mais sans
cela on pourra rien faire dans le
secteur nucléaire
[Musique]
là aussi développe des projets
d'hydrogène et qui peuvent être utilisés
dans les transports la métallurgie le
btp sur la gestion des carbone nous
allons continuer à travailler sur leur
traitement des gaz compte joueur parmi
d'ailleurs les penny extracteur de
pétrole nous sommes peut-être le pq plus
cette technologie pour développer les
structures de transport de gaz et
l'efficacité énergétique au niveau des
logements au niveau des transports avec
un centre de solutions hybrides
ici on a un renouvellement total de la
structure de l'entreprise est évidemment
le lancement de ce type de projet doit
se faire avec les outils de gestion du
marché il ya le système des obligations
vers et y est le critère aussi de
d'efficacité des projets mais pour
résoudre le problème du réchauffement
global toutes ces mesures ne sont pas
suffisantes pour parvenir à ce qu'on
appelle la neutralité carbone il est
important de d'étouffer ses d'absorber
ces rejets dans l'air et là notre
objectif est justement de développer une
technologie une technologie de captage
de ces gaz à partir de toutes les
sources est donc la deuxième orientation
que je propose c'est une industrie c'est
un secteur industriel nouveau c'est un
marché nouveau que nous mettons en place
où il y aura des unités
carbone et ceux qui travaillent dans des
dans l'énergie le connaissent c'est à
dire c'est une sorte d' actifs qui
correspond au volume de rejet captées
sur telle ou telle unité de territoire
sur une unité de forêt par exemple est
donc là il ya des unités carbone qui
sont calculées et il y a aujourd'hui des
pays qui veulent taxer ces unités sur
les transports de produits d'un pays à
l'autre la russie avec toutes ces
toundra ces mares forêts nous avons en
gros au total un cinquième des forêts du
monde et aujourd'hui ces forêts
absorbent des millions de tonnes hélas
le potentiel de la nature présente en
russie est très important pour
l'ensemble de la planète et en raison de
ses avantages naturels la russie peut
jouer un rôle particulier ici dans cette
gestion des unités carbone et augmenter
la capacité d'absorption et de captation
ici est très important
avec la gestion des des phénomènes qui
se produisent enfants en forêt avec les
les incendies etc
mais il ya un travail de restauration de
rétablissement qui se fait ici et là
nous pouvons obtenir un effet qui est
triple c'est à dire qu'en investissant
des moyens des technologies dans la
gestion au niveau de l'habitation des
des gens deuxièmement on crée des
emplois dans un secteur industriel
hautement technologies et troisièmement
nous assurons une capacité
concurrentielle importante et et cela je
sais que ça consomme beaucoup de gens
qui sont aussi présents dans cette salle
c'est à dire que ici c'est un défi qui
est lancé aux entreprises russes qui
achètent ou qui veulent racheter des
unités carbone à l'étranger alors que au
lieu de faire ça on pourrait investir
dans des projets climatiques au niveau
de notre pays et là il ya un avantage
économique qui est certain ce sera plus
efficace du point de vue économique et
pourrait développer à l'avenir
dans ce contexte je voudrais dire que
selon les experts
les recettes de cette industrie va
constituer 50 milliards de dollars par
an c'est une volée très très profitable
pour les entreprises russes et
étrangères et nous invitons nos
partenaires à y participer
nous allons créer des conditions pour
susi je vais m'y attarder puisqu'il ya
quelques question est très pertinente
pour des projets climatiques en russie
il faut voir quels seraient les critères
de ces projets voir quels seront les
territoires et qu'elles seront les
technologies à utiliser
il faut mettre en place
système d'évaluation très transparente
de ces projets écologiques
il faut mettre au point les normes de
cette capacité d'absorption de ces sites
et il faut calculer ses unités carbone
dont je parle et il faut voir quel
serait le système de suivi de ces
projets en utilisant l'espace les
technologies numériques et
l'intelligence artificielle
ce système national a en utilisant le
potentiel de notre science est en cours
de développement en russie nous créons
un réseau de polygones carbone ou nous
contrôlons et les émissions de carbone
en temps réel
on évalue la situation des des espaces
écologiques d'autres paramètres
nous mettons en place le marché carbone
sur le territoire de l'île de sakhaline
c'est une grande et démarche dans la
voix pour obtenir la neutralité carbone
et la création de notre marché de vente
et achat de dignité carbone je sais
qu'il ya des
projets similaires dans d'autres pays et
il faut obtenir la reconnaissance
mutuelle des émissions et de captage et
bien sûr pour cela nous avons besoin des
statistiques transparente confiance
mutuelle entre les états et bien sûr des
recherches conjointes entre les états
nous sommes ouverts pour cette
coopération
ici le 1er juillet 2022 le gouvernement
doit créer un cadre normatif dans ce
domaine au niveau fédéral mais au niveau
des de toutes sortes de normes pour que
nos partenaires étrangers soient
capables de réaliser leurs projets sur
le territoire russe
sur la base des règles compréhensible sa
collègue en terminant mon intervention
je voudrais redire que malgré toutes les
épreuves suite à la pandémie
nous revenons à la vie normale alors un
exemple éclatant c'est notre forum à
saint pétersbourg et la semaine suivante
saint pétersbourg va accueillir les
matches de la coupe d'europe de football
1 et je voudrais adresser mes voeux à
notre grand ami
l'émir de qatar qui a fêté son
anniversaire hier
bon anniversaire je suis certain que le
qatar va organiser avec succès la coupe
du monde de football ses forums
réunissent les gens nous rapproche les
chefs d'entreprises qui seront présents
dans cette salle savent que ce dialogue
direct et franc galvanise les projets
d'affaires et l'économie mondiale la
russie va créer toutes les opportunités
pour ce dialogue pour les échanges
d'expériences pour montrer
les innovations dans les technologies
nouvelles
je vous souhaite un très beau travail
durant ce forum merci monsieur poutine
vous avez annoncer une grande nouvelle à
propos de nord stream 2 et nous allons
en parler
et comme notre discussion mais je
voudrais simplement préciser une chose
vous avez cité les pme comme soutien de
l'économie
et on sait quelle est la part du secteur
public en russie et la cour des comptes
ici monsieur koudrine pour le confirmer
c'est à dire la part des pme doit
augmenter
vous avez cité les moyens et donc on va
dépenser un certain nombre de ressources
pour cela dit moi cet argent va aller
directement dans le secteur public ou
d'investisseurs privés
comment vous allez repartir tout ça je
crois qu'il s'agit du bon sens je mise
sur le bon sens durant la crise toujours
un partout dans le monde dans tout le
pays
la part du secteur public est en hausse
ça se passe partout et une stabilisation
une fois stabilisés
la part des entreprises privées commence
à grandir
li a rien de nouveau dans ce si nous
avons des grandes entreprises avec la
participation publique par exemple
gazprom et rosneft
mais c'est la participation de l'état
ce ne sont pas des entreprises publiques
à 100% mais nous comprenons très bien
que nous devons avancer vers la
privatisation nous le faisons j'ai
mentionné par exemple l'entreprise de
nos approches neft
ou bien ce verbe hannequin là nous avons
une moitié de fonctionnaires étrangers
environ 45 7% mais je ne dirais pas
qu'il ya une différence entre la russie
et d'autres pays
ce ne serait pas correct et mais de quoi
je parle
comment on va se tenir y compris grâce à
nos grandes entreprises avec une
participation publique les pme mais les
pme privées et nous voulons qu'ils les
achètent des biens et des services qui
sont produits par des pme
ils le font au niveau de bain 5% c'est
le soutien direct des pme du secteur
privé et si on parle de ce processus de
privatisation on continue la
privatisation mais avec précaution
est-ce qu'il faut vendre des entreprises
ou pas mais de façon radicale notre
objectif c'est de développer les
relations de libre marché et développer
les entreprises privées attirer les
investisseurs
miral je propose qu'on demande à l'émir
al thani et de s'exprimer encore une
fois bon anniversaire passé à vous à
vous la parole
merci beaucoup
votre excellence le président poutine
mesdames et messieurs avant tout je
voudrais remercier son excellence le
président poutine pour cette invitation
à prendre part à ce forum qui a lieu
dans votre magnifique vul ville le
centre de la culture de l'art la ville
qui a résisté face à l'ennemi durant la
deuxième guerre mondiale et je vous en
remercie pour cette invitation
notre forum se passe dans le contexte
des grands défis les défis pour
l'économie mondiale pour chaque pays
suite à la pandémie de la coronavirus
avec tous ses impacts sur l'économie
mondiale
c'est pourquoi ce forum est très
importante du point de vue du
développement de l'économie mondiale
c'est aussi que l'exemple pour toute la
communauté mondiale puisque ici nos
lançons des initiatives pour obtenir la
reprise de l'économie et pour rechercher
des solutions économiques communes bien
sûr que la participation internationale
à ce forum reflète un rôle particulier
de la russie que dans les processus
mondiaux et régionaux
cher participants au forum le qatar est
fier des relations historiques avec la
russie qui ont reçu leur développement
durant les deux dernières décennies dans
des secteurs économiques politiques dans
le commerce
également dans le domaine des
investisseurs nous sommes des leaders
parmi les investisseurs étrangers en
russie et dans ce contexte nous
confirmons notre appréciation de la le
haut degré de notre coopération de notre
interaction en particulier dans le
secteur d'énergie et nous réaffirmons
notre certitude de cette coopération
le volume de nos investissements ont
doublé les dernières années et nous
espérons que cette tendance va perdurer
cette coopération économique avec le
qatar et la russie ne courait pas
uniquement les investissements directs
c'est aussi est la coordination pour
soutenir cette coopération
nos deux états ensemble avec d'autres
états ont fondé le forum des pays
exportateurs exportateurs de gaz dont le
siège est à doha le qatar transfert
revit cette grande période de
développement suite à notre programme
vision 2020 2030 est notre priorité ce
sont les investissements dans
l'infrastructure les projets de
développement de l'éducation le
transport la recherche les pme
nous voulons diversifier notre économie
et augmenter les investissements du
secteur privé dans tous les domaines de
l'économie en stimulant le partenariat
entre
les entreprises privées et le secteur
public
nous voulons attirer les investissements
étrangers
les projets économiques du qatar
garantissent les opportunités pour les
entreprises étrangères qui participait
dans le développement des secteurs de
différents secteurs de l'économie de
notre pays nous avons apporté des
amendements dans notre législation qui
stimule le secteur privé et les
investissements étrangers ce qui crée un
environnement propice pour les
investissements étrangers
nous voulons augmenter les
investissements dans l'énergie verte le
développement durable qui protège
l'environnement et contribuer à la lutte
contre le changement climatique
mesdames et messieurs la pandémie de
l'aco vite de 19 à montrer
l'interdépendance des peuples et a
confirmé le fait que pas un seul état
n'est capable de faire face à cette
pandémie
les investissements dans les moyens de
lutte contre la pandémie devrait être le
patrimoine de chat de toute l'humanité
il faut obtenir l'accessibilité aux
vaccins pour les pays pauvres et les
pays qui souffrent des guerres et de
l'instabilité
nous voulons que la santé des gens ne
soient pas en fonction des guerres et
j'apprécie beaucoup le rôle de la russie
dans la production des vaccins fiable le
développement de l'économie de
l'investissement à la base des valeurs
universelles
c'est la voie universelle pour créer les
moyens de lutte contre les pandémies
mais aussi contre le changement
climatique
c'est aussi un une seule voix pour
renouer avec une vie normale il faut
soutenir nos établissements médicaux ne
recherche dans la médecine pour fournir
les vaccins à tous les gens et nous
portons l'attention des entreprises
privées au milieu très confortable au
qatar pour réaliser des grands projets
dans le domaine
pour terminer je voudrais redire mes
remerciements au président poutine pour
m'avoir éviter et pour choisir le qatar
en tant qu'invité d'honneur du forum
nous voulons obtenir les résultats et
les objectifs que nous posons la paix et
pour tout et pour tous monsieur le
chancelier fédéral nous attendons aussi
votre point de vue sur l'évolution de
l'économie internationale et après nous
aurons une discussion sur monsieur
poutine excellence l'émir al thani
mesdames messieurs je suis très heureux
de pouvoir représenter l'autriche à ce
forum de saint pétersbourg
comme l'ont dit avant moi les autres
intervenants le monde au cours de ces
dix derniers mois a beaucoup changé en
raison de la pandémie et
de la chine de la crise qui a frappé
notre économie et donc c'est un très bon
sac très bon signe que nous puissions
avoir cette rencontre aujourd'hui dans
ce forum est que nous puissions regarder
positivement l'avenir
il ya des centaines de millions de
personnes qui ont été frappés par ce
virus qui ont été touchés et il ya eu
beaucoup de limitations à notre
communication à nos échanges et ça a été
la plus grosse crise de ces dernières
décennies
il ya évidemment une baisse de la
croissance économique il ya beaucoup les
deux d'emplois qui ont été perdus
mais grâce à dieu nous voyons
aujourd'hui les premiers signes de
rétablissement de l'économie
et cela confirme les prévisions que nous
avions fait aujourd'hui certains
secteurs économiques reprennent
c'est le cas du secteur et comme secteur
du tourisme par exemple et notre
objectif est de réussir
au cours de cette année 2021 décide de
retrouver les niveaux d'avant la crise
mais cela n'est possible que si chaque
pays en particulier et vainqueur du
coronavirus et si nous travaillons
ensemble et cela est plus important
encore que qu'auparavant je sais que ce
n'est pas toujours possible parce que
différentes parties et différentes
parties du monde sont divisés par des
conceptions politiques mais il ya aussi
d'autres aspects qui sont importants et
cela fait partie des droits
démocratiques et si nous rencontrons
tout le monde est accueillant chacun
c'est le moyen de pouvoir discuter
et malgré toutes les différences qui
peut y avoir nous pouvons dans
différents secteurs travailler ensemble
et chercher des moyens de coopérer
aujourd'hui je voudrais indiquer de
trois domaines qui sont importants le
premier c'est de vaincre ensemble de
surmonter ensemble cette crise c'est
d'utiliser en com et ensuite c'est
travailler ensemble à la croissance
économique et le troisième point c'est
lutter contre les dommages économiques
qui vient et comme vous l'avez dit
monsieur poutine
nous devons continuer à travailler
ensemble et la crise nous a montré que
en tant que nation en tant qu'etat nous
allons résister encore plus à à ce fléau
si nous travaillons ensemble
il ya un certain temps nous espérions
qu'un vaccin serait trouvée pour vaincre
l'épidémie et retrouver une vie normale
pour l'été et finalement nous voyons que
cet espoir est satisfait et cela est la
preuve de la force de la science et de
la puissance de la coopération
cela n'aurait pas été possible si nous
n'avions pas travaillé ensemble dans le
plan de la science sur le plan de la
science et sur le plan politique aussi
et est ce que le vaccin d'où qu'il
vienne que ce soit de chine de russie
d'europe d'amérique de toute façon tous
les efforts qui sont faits ce sont des
efforts qui sont faits au nom de du
monde entier quelques quelles que soient
les différences politiques ici et nous
ne pouvons vaincre que si nous nous ne
vaincrons que quand les vaccins seront
accessibles à tous les habitants
et cela doit être au coeur de notre
coopération nous soutenons cette
démarche
l'onu a lancé cette initiative de faire
en sorte que chacun où qu'il habite sur
la planète fussent avoir accès aux
vaccins et je suis très heureux de voir
que le vaccin spoutnik v est représentée
dans plus de 60 pays et qui le maître
livrer partout je tiens à vous remercier
monsieur président poutine pour votre
initiative en la matière car
effectivement tout grande partie de dés
pays dans le monde pourront participer à
cette lutte contre le corona virus et il
s'agissit d'assurer le bien-être des
gens ce n'est pas seulement une menace
parce que le virus n'est pas seulement
une menace pour nous c'est une menace
pour nos échanges pour notre économie en
général il ya toujours eu des liens de
plus en plus étroits entre nos économies
c'est dans ces dix dernières années et
c'est important ici que nous puissions
travailler justement l'autriche est un
bon exemple ici parce que nous avons su
travailler un peu partout dans le monde
à établir des réseaux
nous exportons beaucoup et la russie 1
est un de nos partenaires majeurs sur ce
plan ça représente 5 milliards d'euros
ses échanges commerciaux avec la russie
est donc cette coopération étroite doit
se poursuivre et il faut retrouver le
niveau d'avant la crise cela va dans nos
intérêts que notre export notre
exportations puisse retrouver le niveau
d'avant
nous avons évidemment souffert de la
pandémie
mais il ya aussi d'autres menaces il n'y
a pas seulement le coronavirus il ya
d'autres menaces dans le monde
il ya par exemple le protectionnisme et
vous savez que l'organisation du
commerce international en 1995 avait
lancé donc un blanc contre ce
protectionnisme
or ces derniers temps cet engagement
semble être mis remis en question et je
pense encore une fois ici que ces
manifestations sont passés dangereuse il
y à différents modèles de commercial
modèle de liberté économique liberté
commerciale et je pense que tous les
pays doivent agir de façon honnête et
transparente pour que toutes les normes
du commerce international soit respecté
dans l'idée du respect de l'égalité des
droits et nous nous devons nous ne
devons pas renoncer aux principes que
nous avons adoptée mais nous devons
préserver ce modèle est qu'il s'agisse
de la lutte contre la pandémie
d'autres luxe telles que la reprise
économique est un autre point qui est
important c'est la lutte contre les
changements climatiques
cela peut être au coeur de notre
activité et ce n'est que si tous les
pays s'unissent dans ce travail et je
pense qu'un certain nombre de pays on
cherchait justement à être conscients de
ça être responsable de des engagements
pris à paris la communauté scientifique
ici un rôle important mais un rôle
important mais nous devons continuer
nous devons impliquer les secteurs
économiques mettre en place les
innovations qui ont été trouvées pour
que l puissent bénéficier à tout le
monde pour limiter les rejets de co2
dans l'air et nous devons élaborer si
des standards applicable à l'ensemble du
monde
la commissaire de l'union européenne sur
ces questions on avait parlé c'est 55%
c'est les réductions que nous devons
obtenir d'ici 2030
vous savez que nous avons pris une
mesure importante nous avons investi
beaucoup de milliards d'euros dans ce
programme pour travailler sur ce
problème d'une grande actualité et je
suis convaincu que dans cette lutte
contre les changements climatiques
nous obtiendrons des résultats si nous
travaillons ensemble un avenir vert qui
est tout à fait envisageable pour nos
entreprises pour nos pays en autriche
mesdames messieurs
notre gouvernement s'est fixé un
objectif très ambitieux c'est que jimmy
2024 nous parvenions à la neutralité co2
et sur le plan énergétique justement
nous voulons utiliser de plus en plus
les énergies renouvelables et nous
faisons misons sur sur ses programmes
innovants et nous travaillons nous
menons des recherches scientifiques ici
je rends matière d'hydrogène parce que
c'est une
c'est une voie qui offre des
perspectives et après cette crise due
qu'au guide nous allons développer aussi
travaillé à la modernisation des
bâtiments savait que l'autriche est un
pays petit mais nous sommes
faisons partie intégrante de ce ces
systèmes nous avons lutté contre la
pandémie nous luttons contre les
changements climatiques et nous ce que
nous voulons c'est le bien-être et un
haut niveau de vie partout dans le monde
et malgré toute la cruauté de cette
crise nous devons aller de l'avant
travailler ensemble dans tous les
secteurs et je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le chancelier
je crois que ce sujet de l'énergie verte
et le vaccin ce sera un grand sujet de
nos discussions mais une seule est
question vous avez dit que vous êtes
pour l'élargissement de notre
coopération
monsieur poutine a visité l'autriche
vous êtes rencontrés et le président
russe a pris la parole devant les chefs
d'entreprise autrichien et le président
russe et disait que vous êtes au courant
des défaillances du climat
d'investissement en russie
mais le président russe a promis
d'améliorer le climat est ce qu'à votre
avis le président russe a tenu sa parole
premièrement je voudrais dire que nos
liens économiques avec la russie et se
développe depuis des décennies c'est
très positif
il y à une augmentation l'élargissement
et la pandémie n'a rien changé dans
notre volonté bien sûr on va sortir de
cette crise comme vous l'avez dit en
2018 le président russe à visiter
l'autriche sur invitation du président
autrichien
on a parlé des opportunités de
coopération économique
et nous sommes très contents de notre
développement du développement de notre
coopération et bien sûr le préjudice
causé par la pandémie aux liens
économiques et bien surmontable nous
avons cette possibilité de continuer
cette activité d'investissement et notre
coopération économique
c'est une base solide pour le
développement de l'autriche et de la
russie nous avons beaucoup de secteurs
d'économie où nous pouvons coopérer
c'est la pharmacie construction
mécanique d'autres secteurs qui sont la
base de la coopération et c'est gagnant
gagnant pour nos deux pays et je crois
que notre coopération dans ces secteurs
va se développer
évidemment il ya toujours des choses sur
lesquelles nous devons travailler nous
avons déjà fait beaucoup de ce que nous
avions prévu
je pense par exemple à la création à la
maison à la réduction de la spec
bureaucratique d'un certain nombre
d'activités liées à la gestion de
l'énergie
je pense que ces derniers dernières
années nous avons fortement améliorer
cet aspect je vois bien qu'il ya encore
des progrès à faire il ya d'autres
questions encore lié aussi à la
simplification bureaucratique des
démarches liées à l'activité économique
qu'il s'agisse cela ne concerne pas que
la russie mais ça concerne notamment des
opérateurs étrangers qui viennent
investir dans notre pays d'ailleurs vous
savez il ya des classements à
l'international qui sont effectués c'est
pas toujours forcément très
objectivement fin la russie progresse
fortement
selon un certain nombre de critères dans
ces classements l'international et je
dirais que le plan
que nous devons suivre ne faisons pas ça
pour être pour faire plaisir à quelqu'un
mais c'est pour nous mêmes et
l'augmentation des échanges commerciaux
et d'investissements notamment dans les
deux sens entre l'autriche et la russie
a augmenté
il ya eu des grands projets que nous
faisons notamment nord stream était
justement montre que nous sommes sur la
bonne voie et que nous réalisons les
plans que nous avons fixés que nous
avons définies et je suis heureux de
voir que les autres et chair de sang et
merci beaucoup
maintenant nous allons visionner le mot
de bienvenue de monsieur alberto
fernandez le président de la nation
argentine
chers collègues
chers amis pour moi c'est un grand
honneur de participer à ce forum
organisé dans le cadre de ce forum
économique de saint-pétersbourg c'est
une grande possibilité pour un non et de
réfléchir à la situation où se trouve le
monde au début de la pandémie
la première question qui se pose à
savoir est ce que notre économie était
assez fiable et nous connaissons cette
réponse le monde le monde était
organisée de sorte que l'économie
mondiale affiche et sa faiblesse
le virus qui représente une menace à la
vie humaine a su porter le préjudice à
la santé de millions de personnes et est
frappé l'économie mondiale est forcé de
réfléchir qu'elle serait quand même
l'économie mondiale dans l'avenir nous
avons vu avec vous que l'économie qui
existait avant la pandémie créer des
disparités des inégalités favoriser la
concentration des profits dans les mains
de d'une minorité a favorisé la misère
des grands des populations c'est la
logique de nombreuses années il faut
revoir cette logique puisque si la
pandémie nous a donné une leçon
cette leçon serait nous devons être
solidaires
nous avons vu avec vous vous durant la
pandémie que personne ne peut se sauver
seul 1 il faut travailler ensemble pour
avoir un avenir meilleur et c'est comme
ça que nous aurons c'est à venir durant
la pandémie nos avons vu l'augmentation
de la pauvreté la hausse du chômage
l'augmentation des besoins du monde qui
est loin d'être un monde développé je ne
parle pas des pays très pauvres mais des
pays et je dirais aux revenus moyens
comme l'argentine
on dit que l'argentine c'est un pays
assez développé mais malheureusement ne
sont plutôt proches d'un pays pauvre et
c'est pour ça que la communauté
internationale devrait prendre des
mesures rapport contribuer au
développement des pays aux revenus
moyens puisque nous avons des
difficultés au niveau des dettes à à des
taux énorme
nous devons à rembourser ses dettes à
avec des délais très courts et c'est
très difficile pour notre pays ce qui ne
permet pas un autre pays de se
développer
et cela montre que le capitalisme que
nous avons connus avant la pandémie ne
donne pas des bons résultats
il génère des inégalités et si nous
voulons construire un autre capitalisme
ce capitalisme ne doit pas oublier la
solidarité et pour moi c'est une grande
leçon de cette pandémie il faut
travailler ensemble
le moment est venu pour les grandes
puissances et les pauvres sont victimes
du virus merci je vous remercie les le
président brésilien gr ball sonara c'est
aussi pour cela rousset au site adresse
adressé aux participants du forum
excellence monsieur le président la nuit
faut-il chercher d'état et de
gouvernement à mesdames messieurs je
remercie le président poutine son
invitation à participer au forum sur les
questions importantes et aux matières
économiques et qui est ce être la
réunion la plus importante dans ce
domaine
les questions abordées concerne le
développement durable dans le monde
le forum de saint pétersbourg est une
sorte de caisse de résonance des
orientations économiques et politiques
pour l'eurasie et ses strass
c'est l'orientation sont stratégiques
pour dans l'optique des nouvelles
transformations que nous connaissons
dans le monde aujourd'hui
l'augmentation principal est évidemment
là
reprise économique après la crise c'est
à dire là il s'agit de revisiter les
principes économiques qui ont été
utilisés jusqu'à présent le brésil
cherche à renforcer la coopération et
l'amitié avec tous les pays de l'espace
eurasiatique et en particulier avec la
russie qui est un partenaire important
et ancien de mon pays le brésil a besoin
de renforcer ses positions tant que
producteur de produits allegra léman
terre et où nous cherchons a su
continuer à assurer cette sécurité
alimentaire l'activité agricole ici un
rôle très important pour très important
seuls 27 % de notre territoire est
exploité de façon par l'agriculture et
nous sommes heureux de savoir que 84 %
de notre territoire relève de l'amazonie
et nous travaillons série d'autres pays
de la région est un facteur important
c'est que notre économie fait partie de
toute une chaîne d'approvisionnement
un alimentaire et le brésil est un des
importateurs clé de d'engrais de
production russe tenons à préserver
cette complémentarité entre la russie et
la et le brésil
en même temps il existe un gros
potentiel de diversification et qui
pourrait contribuer à développer nos
économies l'augmentation vous du volume
des échanges à haute valeur ajoutée est
important et les entrepreneurs de nos
pays joue un rôle important ici dans
l'identification de nouvelles
opportunités
et il est particulièrement important de
renforcer notre coopération en matière
d'investissement
c'est important que nous travaillons
ensemble développions cette coopération
qu'il s'agisse des secteurs de
technologie d'autres
et le voici brésil est tout à fait
ouvert à l'implémentation de nouvelles
technologies' qu'il s'agisse notamment
par exemple de l'intelligence
artificielle
je souhaite un plein succès à ce forum
économique international de saint
pétersbourg et je me joins aux
représentants des milieux d'affaires et
des milieux politiques qui sont
impliqués ici qu'ils s'engagent à
développer le développant assurer le
développement durable de notre société
ici je vous remercie
monsieur le président j'ai écouté ses
messages et je me demandais pourquoi
est-ce que nous sommes ensemble ici est
ce que c'est la fin de la pandémie
nous nous sommes réunis tout en
respectant les consignes des
spécialistes des médecins qui disent que
on peut se réunir dans ce format mais
malheureusement nous n'avons pas réussi
à accueillir ici les chefs d'état qui
participent à notre session plénière en
visioconférence parce que quand un chef
d'état arrive une grande délégation
l'accompagnent il est très difficile de
respecter tous les gestes barrières et
sait très bien que dans la salle
les gens portent un masque de nombreux
sont chez eux une situation s'est
améliorée en russie par rapport à
d'autres pays mais il faut avoir des
précautions
c'est la saison estivale il ya beaucoup
de contacts
malheureusement de nombreuses en couille
tinue a estimé que cela ne les concerne
pas ignore les gestes barrière mais la
situation en russie à saint pétersbourg
nous permet quand même à d'organiser ce
forum sans risque d'être contaminé c'est
en fonction de la situation en russie
très bien avant de poser des questions
économiques
je voudrais poser une question
importante le football monsieur l'émir
bien sûr nous serait très intéressé par
la tenue des jeux olympiques qui ont été
reportées pour le moment on ignore de
quelle façon on va organiser les jeux
olympiques et une question se pose
en 2018 le président poutine a remis un
ballon de football et symbolique au
qatar à la fifa a estimé que la coupe du
monde de football en russie était parmi
les meilleurs
est ce que le qatar va battre ce record
comment vous vous préparez à
l'organisation de cette coupe du monde
est ce que cette coupe du monde de
football aura lieu
est-ce que la pandémie a eu son impact
oui bien sûr vous avez dit que le
précédent poutine noah a remis un ballon
de football symbolique en 2018 un
réalité tout ce que la russie a fait
grâce notamment aux efforts du président
poutine et je sais que nos collègues du
qatar qui sont qui travaillent au sein
de la fifa
il faut tout leur possible pour
organiser la coupe du monde au qatar
nous nous préparons à cet événement et
nous estimons que tout retard dans
l'organisation et la construction des
stades de football n'est pas admissible
nous voulons organiser cette coupe du
monde
dans les délais prévus ça sera en
novembre et en novembre d'ailleurs nous
aurons une répétition de la coupe du
monde
la pandémie à affecter non seulement
notre pays nous affichons un certain
retard dans la construction de certains
sites
mais ce n'est pas critique le système de
transport est déjà prêt les fera
structure est prête et bien sûr le qatar
sera prête à accueillir à la coupe du
monde 1 et comme c'est déjà dit la
russie en 2018
bien sûr à afficher des excellents
résultats en organisant une excellente
coupe du monde et le monde entier en est
et demain bien sûr vous avez relevé la
barre est très haut et nous allons
utiliser l'expérience russe et nous
espérons que la russie vend nos cités à
organiser la coupe du monde au qatar
d'une façon excellente mais cette barre
haute
c'est en quelque sorte notre repère et
j'espère qu'on va réussir âge donc si on
revient à l'agenda d'aujourd'hui le
président poutine vient d'ajouter ici
l'annoncé une visite d'une information
importante avec à propos du nord stream
2 et vous monsieur le chancelier fédéral
il y avait des sanctions qui avait été
introduite qui avaient reporté la mise
en exploitation de nos ressentis selon
vous est ce qu'il y ait est-ce qu'il ya
toujours un risque que le projet ne soit
pas réalisée jusqu'au bout et y at il
une probabilité que par exemple
après l'achèvement de la construction le
gaz est lancé mais il ne parvient pas au
consommateur est ce que c'est possible
oui c'est vrai que et les entreprises
autrichiennes participent à ce projet et
à l'instar de l'allemagne et d'autres
pays européens suivants le développement
de ce projet de façon positive et bien
sûr les intérêts d'autres pays comme la
grèce entre dans ce projet
cela dit
ce trajet est construit de façon
correcte et nous espérons que nous
allons obtenir le gaz russe sur le
territoire autrichien comme sur le
territoire d'autres pays puisque nous
avons besoin du ravitaillement en gaz
russe
et bien sûr nord stream ii nous confère
une sécurité énergétique et j'estime que
qu'il faut terminer ce projet sous
conditions qui ont été arrêtées selon
nos évaluations
c'est un projet très positif nous sommes
optimistes et nous espérons que ce
projet serait réalisé serait terminée à
l'instar de l'allemagne
également nous espérons que cela va
contribuer à la sécurité énergétique de
l'europe c'est un projet très important
pour la russie
nos achetons beaucoup du gaz russe c'est
vrai est ce que le il ya toujours un
risque que l'exploitation ou la mise en
service soit empêchée par les
restrictions américaines
je voudrais redire je l' ai dit à
maintes reprises
c'est un projet purement commerciale est
purement économique
ceux qui estiment que cela va porter
préjudice à d'autres pays
qui transfère le gaz c'est pas vrai
puisque ce trajet qui passe par la mer
baltique de russie en allemagne
si on prend le total de kilomètres
ce trajet est plus courant je le redis
ce trajet est plus court qu'à travers
les pays européens l'ukraine la
slovaquie l'autriche ce trajet et moins
coûteux et plus court deuxième chose là
il n'y a aucun risque politique
il ne faut pas payé pour le transit du
gaz puisque c'est plus logique du point
de vue économique cela veut dire que le
consommateur final en allemagne les
entreprises dans les pays européens vont
payer moins qu'aujourd'hui c'est
raisonnable du point de vue économique
on l'a redit à maintes reprises mais
toujours il y à cette sorte de
propagande eux et on nous dit que là il
y à de la politique pour porter
préjudice à quelqu'un non pourquoi nos
partenaires sont pour ce projet pourquoi
ils luttent pour ce projet pour nous
faire plaisir
non ils luttent pour leurs intérêts
nationaux et justin je pense qu'il faut
terminer ce projet surtout dans les
conditions où la nouvelle administration
américaine
nunzi que qu'il est qu'elle est voudrais
avoir des relations correctes avec leurs
partenaires européens
mais comment le faire mais en même temps
ignorait leurs intérêts nationaux
c'est du non sens en plus le gaz russe
et est le plus propre dans le monde
pourquoi parce que
grâce à la technologie de rupture
hydrauliques les américains obtiennent
environ 1 77%
gazprom 11%
mais tout ce qui est extrait pour le
nord stream ii est directement extraits
tandis que ces technologies de rupture
hydraulique saute ring visible pour
l'écologie puisque on injecte des
centaines de tonnes de produits
chimiques
cela porte le préjudice à l'écologie on
parle beaucoup de l'écologie mais c'est
l'exemple qui est très dangereuse oui on
peut parler également des sanctions mais
là on parle de l'outil de la concurrence
est déloyale et si nous parlons de la
source d'énergie comme le gaz
il ne faut pas oublier que c'est un
produit optimale très demandé pour une
période très longue de cette transition
écologique
vers l'énergie verte
parmi les hydrocarbures c'est le gaz qui
est le plus propre et qui va rester
encore longtemps sur le marché puisque
c'est très écologique et je pense
mesdames et messieurs que ces projets
entrent dans les intérêts non pas de la
russie mais de nos partenaires européens
et ce projet doit être réalisé
j'ai déjà indiquent que nous avons déjà
terminé la première ligne de ce gazoduc
et nous allons bientôt terminé la
deuxième ligne et les livraisons les
prochaines livraisons des ducasses et
c'est pour quand nous avons besoin de
quelques jours monsieur miller est en
face de moi il ne m'en parlait chaque
jour vie nous avons terminé les lignes
il faut les soulever maintenant des
autres des deux extrémités en allemagne
et en russie
les souder cela prend du jour un peu
plus gazprom est prête à fournir le gaz
en utilisant cette ligne de north stream
de je ne sais pas si la délégation
allemande est rentré déjà de washington
il y eut des négociations entre les
allemands et les américains
là ils ont parlé de la coopération mais
le gaz américain est plus cher
de 20 5% ou bien acheter moins cher le
gaz russe qui est produit et de façon
plus écologique ou bien acheter du gaz
américain qui a acheté en utilisant une
technologie qui n'est pas écologique
voilà oui la différence mais 70% du gaz
américain est extrait en utilisant des
technologies qui ne seront pas
écologique il faut être franc et tirait
des conclusions quelles sont les
conclusions ici c'est plus écologique
c'est moins coûteux c'est plus fiable
alors nos partenaires ont fait leur
choix
c'est le gaz russe mais il faut dire
aussi que les huit existantes de gaz
nourrissent des pays anti renom
nourrissent ces pays mais le président
ukrainien a des qui aura pas d'argent
pour l'armée s'il n'y a pas de transit
de gaz russe à travers l'ukraine
une fois que nord stream 2 sera achevée
on aura plus du gaz de transit
cette vente est monsieur peskov le porte
parole du kremlin de dire quelques mots
là-dessus mais je dirais moi aussi nous
avons un contrat avec l'ukraine qui
concerne le transit du gaz russe
il s'agit pour les cinq prochaines
années environ 40 mille tonnes de mètres
cubes
oui nous avons fourni du gaz en europe
en 2018 c'était environ 200 milliards de
mètres cubes 1 dans le cas des relations
assez normal on aurait la possibilité de
continuer ce travail mais ce ne sont pas
des problèmes politiques ce sont des
problèmes économiques puisque ce
monopole de transit du gaz engendre une
sorte d'illusion qu'il faut augmenter
les prix du transit et de l'autre côté
essayé de baisser le prix du gaz qui est
acheté pour le cren dans des contacts
directs entre l'ukraine et la russie
c'est très mauvais le ponot monopole et
il ne s'agit pas de la politique puisque
cela a commencé
auparavant nous avons est signé le
mémorandum avec l'ukraine
l'ancien chancelier allemand monsieur
coderre et moi même
le président ukrainien koutchma ont
signé le mémorandum qui est constitué un
consortium avec la participation de
l'ukraine la russie les partenaires
européens l'allemagne et d'autres pays
et cela reste la propriété de l'état
ukrainien qui va maintenir le gazoduc
ensuite monsieur iouchtchenko qui est
venu au pouvoir en ukraine a annulé l ce
contrat ensuite il ya eu un scandale
avec le transit de gaz russe puisque
l'ukraine a bloqué le transit ce sont
les risques
non il ne s'agit pas des financements
des forces armées maintenant le cren
obtient 1,5 milliard de dollars mais il
pourrait avoir cinq ou six milliards de
dollars suite au transit du gaz russe
mais nous partons du fait que les
livraisons du gaz russe en europe seront
augmentés de 50 milliards de mètres
cubes plus cette année au premier
trimestre de cette année nous pouvons
obtenir un record l'année passée c'était
180 milliards de mètres cubes 1
cette année ça sera deux milliards de
mètres cubes au mieux vaut bien plus
puisque il y à leur établissement
la relance de l'économie mais durant les
dix prochaines années nous aurons
l'augmentation de 50 milliards de mètres
cubes un cas nous pourrions utiliser ce
gazoduc qui passent par le territoire
ukrainien
après l'échéance de notre contrat avec
le cren tout est possible nous sommes
prêtes à le faire mais nous le voulons
mais nous avons besoin de la bonne
volonté de la part
de nos partenaires ukrainiens n'ont pas
pour avoir beaucoup d'argent pour
entretenir et les forces armées et
penser à des solutions de force pour
régler le problème du donbass nom pour
relancer l'économie pour travailler avec
les gens nous partons du fait que nous
avons des relations compliquées avec les
autorités ukrainiennes mais nous pensons
à la vie des gens en ukraine dans le
cadre des relations normales avec
l'ukraine à l'intérieur du pays
nous avons le prix du gaz au niveau 2 62
dollars pour mille mètres cubes 1 mais
en ukraine et c'est beaucoup plus alors
le prix pour les gens c'est 350 dollars
c'est beaucoup plus c'est le triple vous
voyez que les ukrainiens paye beaucoup
plus nous voulons avoir des relations
normales économique avec l'ukraine et
nous y sommes prêtes et nous misons sur
le bon sens et nous le voulons
regarde sur le marché du gaz de façon
plus
jol général pas seulement innocenté mais
de manière généralement une discussion
plénière il ya l'autriche qui à l'euro
il ya la russie le qatar qui ont le gaz
expliqué nous s'il vous plaît pourquoi
ce gaz dans la zone euro pourquoi la
russie et le qatar
le vendent en dollars qu on va commencer
par vous monsieur le chancelier pourquoi
vous acheter du gaz de russie et pas
seulement d'ailleurs mais en dollar si
vous avez des euros je pense qu'on peut
répondre de façon très simple à cette
question il ya un système international
et donc les prix sur le marché sont
calculés en dollars
et pour cette raison notre
monnet a une valeur importante mais
c'est un système qui fonctionne qui
montre qu'il fonctionne depuis longtemps
et je pense que ces dix dernières années
notre entreprise s'est bien développé et
bien sûr nous avons besoin de sécurité
énergétique et cette question pour
l'autriche s'appuie sur un certain
nombre de facteurs différents et
enseignants c'est pour ça que nous avons
développé les énergies renouvelables et
d'ici 2030 nous voudrions avoir 100 %
d'utilisation d'énergies renouvelables
mais il existe toujours encore une
nécessité d'utiliser de consommer du gaz
et du pétrole et c'est pour ça que nous
avons de bonnes relations avec un
certain nombre de pays et nous avons un
travail qui se fait en toute sécurité
entre nous c'est pour ça que nous
regardons le considérant ce d'un oeil
tout à fait positif le projet north
stream the nous voulons économiser pas
seulement sur le transit mais nous
voulons miser sur la sécurité en ce qui
concerne le cren évidemment nous
voudrions que la situation en ukraine
soit réglé et je pense que la
coopération internationale doit se
renforcer doit se développer parce que
plus il ya de stabilité
mieux c'est pour le développement
économique pas seulement en europe mais
partout dans le monde
je reviens à l'euro vous dites que ce
système était assez rodée mais c'était
au siècle dernier vous dites que ce
système est fiable
mais ici nous avons un acteur tiers qui
pourrait bloquer les paiements à tout
moment où est la sécurité de paiement
je ne comprends pas le premier c'est que
le marché calculé dans le centre du
monde en dollars américains
et donc c'est une mesure qui a été
adopté évidemment on peut payer en euros
mais ce que je veux dire de notre point
de vue ça doit pas être une question
géopolitique
pour nous c'est une question purement
économique et qui se pose simplement
calcul de prix les prix sont calculés en
dollars même si c'est pas important ont
finalement manqué quelle que soit la
l'unité monétaire dans laquelle ils sont
faits si on orientait vers le
développement durable je pense qu'il
faut préserver nos ressources
réfléchir à la façon de transporter
l'économie et notre attention est
concentrée précisément sur ce point
évidemment nous regardons comment
agissent les grandes puissances sur les
modes de paiement nous nous sommes un
petit pays et pour nous la question la
plus importante c'est la question de la
sécurité et non pas celle de la valeur
monétaire
monsieur le président et pour vous
quelle est la réponse nous avons besoin
d'une stabilité de la pratique
prévisibilité et la devise c'est pas
important mais le troisième acteur si
l'émetteur est représentée par les états
unis qui qui n'apprécie pas sa monnaie
nationale comme monnaie de réserve et
qui l'utilisent cette monnaie pour un
outil de protectionnisme bien sûr cela
porte préjudice à l'économie mondiale ce
ne sont pas nos évaluations c'est ce
sont les évaluations de la banque
mondiale les réserves en or et en
devises sont en baisse y compris les
réserves des états unis et les paiements
en dollars sont en baisse mais nos
opérateurs pour le moment préfèrent
avoir des transactions en dollars mais
les dollars détermine quand même les
prix et du pétrole et puisque c'est un
produit qui est coté en bourse mais de
toute façon nous sommes prêtes à
organiser des paiements avec d'autres
pays en utilisant d'autres devises par
exemple
utiliser l'europe puis pour nos l'euro
c'est une devise assez fiable pour le
gaz par exemple mais je crois que si on
renonce au dollar dans le pétrole ça
serait un grand coup dur pour l'économie
mondiale
cela dit non ne voulons pas utiliser ces
outils dans une sorte de
davanture politique mais cette logique
de développement du système économique
mondial nous dit qu'il faut quand même
quelques devises de réserve pourrait
garantir la stabilité du système
financier mondial
excellence quel est votre avis comment
se positionne aussi le qatar en tant qu'
un des principaux fournisseurs notamment
de gaz liquéfié sur le marché du gaz
si effectivement aussi l'europe assad et
à une plus grande neutralité énergétique
comment vous voyez les choses vous met
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit le
qatar joue un grand rôle dans les
livraisons de gaz d'ici 2026 notre part
va constituer 40% le gaz liquéfié a une
très bonne qualité et nous utilisons cet
avantage nous coopérons avec de
nombreuses entreprises internationales
et y compris les entreprises russes nous
utilisons l'efficacité de cette
coopération
et bien sûr nous utilisons également des
technologies de pointe nous prenons en
compte la sécurité et écologique
les problèmes de sécurité énergétique
nous allons donc obtenir cet indicateur
de 40% d'ici 2020 6 concernant les pays
exportateurs du gaz j'espère que très
prochainement nous aurons une rencontre
des producteurs de gaz au qatar et et on
va parler des de notre coopération
ultérieure
bien sûr nous sommes chargés d'une
grande responsabilité pour l'avenir de
ce secteur énergétique très important et
il faut dire également que notre avenir
est basée sur l'utilisation est alors
efficace et du gaz est le seul des
sanctions aujourd'hui des sanctions sont
lancées contre la russie la russie on
l'entretient d'autres récemment via une
liste de pays hostiles hostile à l'égard
de la russie pour l'instant sur cette
liste il y en a deux c'est les états
unis et la république tchèque nous
pourrons parler encore monsieur poutine
et comment faire venir des
investissements avec les pays hostiles
grâce au travail avec les gens et les
entreprises dans ces pays qui ne nous
considère comme un ami
la délégation des chefs d'entreprises
américains vient par tradition au forum
de saint pétersbourg
il ya deux ans c'était une délégation la
plus importante plus de 200 cette année
puis 200 participants cette année c'est
cela montre que les entreprises
américaines ont un grand intérêt à
coopérer avec la russie et malgré les
barrières érigées ils conservent leurs
positions en russie
il y à des entreprises étrangères qui
augmente leur capitalisation dans sur le
marché russe en russie ils ont des
actifs importants
cela concerne bien sûr le secteur
énergétique au premier chef et il faut
nos bases et et sur ces gens qui ont du
bon sens et qui veulent coopérer
pourquoi l'attitude les relations entre
la russie et l'europe se sont
sérieusement dégradées ces derniers
temps oui je serai très franc pour moi
c'est un facteur très négatif
je suis très déçu par cette situation
quand j'ai pris cette fonction
j'espérais très bien que ce conflit en
ukraine serait résolu et nous allons
travailler de nouveau dans le domaine de
coopération fructueuse mais ces
dernières années nous avons parlé avec
des les ministres des affaires
étrangères et nous avons constaté que
rien ne change
et cela n'est pas aux intérêts de la
stabilisation de la situation
il ya bien sûr la création de la
situation mais notre objectif l'objectif
de l'autriche c'est de contribuer au
règlement du conflit pour freiner cette
spirale de l'escaladé de la tension il y
à des démarches et qui sont contraires
au droit international
à notre avis et qui sont la cause de
l'aggravation de sa situation en ukraine
bien sûr nous voudrions rechercher des
solutions de sortie de cette crise bien
agréable au niveau diplomatique en
utilisant le format de minsk
il y à beaucoup de pays qui sont
intéressées par le règlement de ce
conflit pour rétablir un dialogue normal
des relations économiques
et justement ce forum économique a pour
objectif de relancer la coopération pour
être ensemble et non pas l'un contre
l'autre et c'est bien correct il faut le
faire tous les acteurs importants savent
que la paix c'est la cause commune il
n'existe pas de paix contre quelqu'un
qui nous sommes partisans de ce concept
nous soutenons toutes les démarches de
l'union européenne
qu'ils nous montrent qu'on prend
conscience qu'il faut éviter
des démarches qui contraire qui sont
contraires au droit international
il faut respecter les intérêts de tous
pour obtenir la stabilité en ukraine en
russie et dans d'autres pays
face à ces limitations extérieur cherche
à développer son potentiel intérieur et
jeu les avons compris que l'année
dernière était difficile pour l'ensemble
du monde beaucoup de gens son bord et
gens continuent à mourir de la pandémie
donc il ya eu deux camps qui se sont
dessinés c'étaient les pays qui ont des
technologies qui ont des ressources pour
sauver les gens pour les soigner et il
ya les pays où nous y'a rien justement
et qui ne s'en sortent pas ça peut être
des pays éloignés de l'europe les états
d'amérique du sud par exemple ici même à
proximité même en ukraine et la russie
malgré les pensées de beaucoup de gens
répondent ses parents tiennent à 10 ans
aujourd'hui que la russie était dans le
premier camp s'étaient intercalés
proposer des soins de santé elle a
proposé des vaccins il ya un soutien à
l'économie mais en même temps que
l'année dernière qui était difficile et
s'est achevée les réserves de la russie
tout a augmenté le budget et le ministre
du budget n'a pas dépensé 3 milliards
1er le milliard de dollars de groupe qui
était prévu c'est à dire que si on met
de l'argent dedans latine dans la tige
de la tirelire
pourquoi les investisseurs privés
doivent-ils pensée qui fait qu'il faille
ne comprend pas très bien cette logique
pourquoi nous n'avons pas utilisé tous
les moyens qui pourraient être utilisés
là il n'y a rien de surprenant puisque
cela arrive très souvent pourquoi parce
que l'argent est destiné à certains
événements mais les opérateurs qui ont
prévu
d'avoir des dépenses pour réaliser ces
projets ne sont pas encore prêts pour
réaliser ses projets de toute façon
c'est une pratique économique assez
habituel est là il n'y a rien de
surprenant
il est vrai que nous avons des
ressources nécessaires c'est vrai cette
année nous aurons le point l'excédent du
budget nous avons la balance commerciale
pour le montant de 146 milliards
nous avons plus de 600 milliards de
dollars de nos réserves et notre fonds
de bien-être national s'élève à 159
milliards de roubles alors ces réserves
sont en hausse le fonds de bien-être
national elle est destinée pour utiliser
dans le cadre de 7% pour des grands
projets d'infrastructures on va bien
calculé tout ça on ne va pas se met à
tort et à travers ces graines comme on
le fait dans l'agriculture
non il faut tout calculer et dépenser
tout pour avoir un effet raisonnable
ce n'est pas que nous n'avons pas cette
volonté de dépenser nous le faisons
puisque nos avons débloqué de grands
moyens et le ministre des finances l'a
dit
je ne me souviens pas de chiffres
concrets mais il y a des centaines de
milliards de roubles qui sont débloqués
pour des projets d'infrastructures des
grands projets et nous essayons
d'investir dans des projets qui sont
rentables
non pas pour aujourd'hui dans une eau à
long terme
mais ce sont des projets économiquement
rentable et c'est une approche correct
du point de vue de l'état nous l'avons
fait nous allons le faire ultérieurement
il s'agit de la construction des chemins
de fer des autoroutes on le fait le
développement de l'industrie
c'est une priorité no investissons dans
des grands projets industriels
monsieur mikkelson a reçu de l'argent de
ce fruit
il le confirme par exemple la production
ducasse liquéfié ensemble avec nos
partenaires français chinois à la russie
soutient ces projets et des blocs ses
moyens en utilisant ce fonds
[Musique]
oleg deripaska qui est devenu un
blogueur que non il l'écrit souvent des
publications à propos de la banque
centrale que les taux sont à quelles
seraient vos commentaires mais je le
peux bien sûr ceux qui ont de l'argent
ou savoir le petit prix mais ce qui
donnait la banque centrale sont chargés
des indicateurs macroéconomiques ces
éducateurs sont les suivants et où est
le problème
hier m
aujourd'hui matters nous avons constaté
qu'il ya deux problèmes actuels pour
aujourd'hui
lesquels le marché du travail il faut
relancer ce marché pour le niveau de 4
7%
maintenant ces 5,2 pour cent le deuxième
problème c'est l'inflation
maintenant les flancs sion s'élève à 5,8
pour cent
je crois que l'expert parle du niveau de
5% le niveau de 5% pour l'année 2000 21
et la banque centrale a maintenu le taux
d'intérêt durant une période assez
longue mais la banque centrale doit
réagir suite à l'évolution de l'économie
russe et monsieur des pères deripaska le
connaît c'est un chef d'entreprise assez
expérimental et bien sûr il veut avoir
le petit prix - soeur mais il faut
retrouver l'équilibré des intérêts bien
sûr
on ne compte pas les tensions
commentaires des blogueurs mais il ya
aussi une autre problème dont parle
beaucoup ces problèmes clé c'est la
pression des services de sécurité
souvent on parle de cela à l'échelle
internationale par exemple la paire
calvi et qui n'a pas été terminé
il ya aussi d'autres exemples on dit que
dans les centres de détention provisoire
il ya un nombre très élevé des hommes
d'affaires les entendra baigneurs
l'annoncé non à moscou rouge effets des
émissions
par exemple je garde des sceaux du buzz
c'est un partenaire qui a passé déjà
quatre ans dans ce jeu le centre de deux
ans sauf qu il soit vous avez dit
victime
il nous semble que si on utilise des
mesures strictes de la vie et deviendra
plus sécurisé mais en fait c'est assez
curieux match t va disparaître parce que
l'institution
c'est moi qui le dit c'était en 96 je ne
le ressens pas non les questions qui
sont liées à au système judiciaire sont
bien d'actualité et là nous pouvons et
devons être très cet actif attentifs
vous connaissez ma position lui bien sûr
les forces de l'ordre protègent les
citoyens l'état mais les entreprises
sont des citoyens qui font honte
une affaire qui est très importante
puisque il crée des emplois et les
garanties c'est le niveau des revenus le
niveau des salaires dans le pays et
je le redis chaque fois il faut être
très attentif à ce qui se passe c'est
pourquoi nous avons créé l institution
du commissaire aux droits de l'homme qui
suivit le respect des droits des
entrepreneurs mais vous serez d'accord
que la qualité de l'entrepreneur je ne
lui donne pas le droit de violer la loi
bien sûr nos devons améliorer notre
système juridique judiciaire nous avons
adopté beaucoup de choses dans le cadre
de l'émulation du cadre normatif
nous avons amélioré le rôle du parquet
des organes enquête et j'espère que cela
va jouer un rôle positif concernant les
gens qui sont en détention provisoire
cela a baissé de 2 fois vous savez c'est
un cas concret il faut voir qu'est ce
qui se passe là je ne vais pas donner
des commentaires
mais puisque vous poser cette question
bien sûr à mon avis il faut être plus
rapide plus que
le procès judiciaire rapide l'enquète et
rapide c'est mieux pour vous le plus
prometteur pour le kata et quel projet
comment peuvent être réalisées qu'est ce
qu'il ya d'intéressant qatar pour les
investisseurs russes
le qatar c'est un des investisseurs en
russie environ 12 milliards de dollars
différents investissements dans
l'infrastructure l'énergie il y à des
entreprises russes qui évoluent sur le
marché du qatar et nous avons de la
confiance en économie russe les
opportunités des entreprises russes un
grand potentiel nous sommes en contact
étroit avec les structures publiques en
russie
nous recherchons ensemble des
opportunités communes pour les
entreprises russes au qatar et j'ai déjà
dit dans mon intervention que nos
investissements vont doubler en russie
ces investissements sont différents
multiples et c'est important pour nous à
la veille de la coupe du monde de
football nous portons une grande
attention au secteur touristique les
touristes
qui est bien un éducateur votre revenir
en russie pour voir les régions russes
et je crois que les russes voudraient
venir au qatar après la pandémie
nous allons investir beaucoup dans le
tourisme dans nos deux pays respectifs
[Musique]
dans un sondage 69% des habitants de
votre bille soutiennent les achats du
vaccin russe poutine qui pour remplacer
le la campagne de vaccination en
autriche je sais qu'il y avait même des
négociations avec le fonds russe dans
six camps acheté deux versants vue si
vous avez dit intervention que ce n'est
pas important d'où vient le vaccin de la
chine de la russie de tropiques mais en
réalité la situation différente pour
l'union européenne c'est quand même
important d'où vient le vaccin dit nous
s'il vous plaît le sujet de vaccins ils
politisent et en europe
écoutez pour nous ce n'est pas un sujet
politique c'est comme je le dis dans mon
intervention
là il ne faut pas prendre en compte les
sujets géopolitique quand il s'agit d'un
vaccin et je suis très heureux que
partout dans le monde dans certains pays
on a développé plusieurs vaccins foot
nick v est apparue sur le marché
très tôt les vaccins de moderna et
d'autres et nous avons la possibilité
d'utiliser différents vaccins là vous
avez raison en autriche
nous avons eu des négociations avec nos
partenaires heureuse
nous avons voulu acheter c'est nick v
mais nous avons la possibilité d'acheter
un vaccin qui est autorisé sur le marché
européen et nous attendons
l'autorisation de ces études sion
européenne cela concerne également
d'autres vaccins et je crois que ça va
durer encore concernant spoutnik vais
j'espère que
pâques c'est vrai sportive et sera
certifié et dans ce cas nous aurons la
possibilité d'acheter ce vaccin russe
spoutnik v et accélérer le processus de
vaccination en autriche pour le moment
nous n'avons pas cette autorisation est
pour le moment pour protéger notre
population nous utilisons d'autres
vaccins qui sont déjà autorisés dans
l'union européenne
malheureusement pour le moment cela ne
concerne pas ce pique nique mais pour le
moment nous avons vacciné environ 50 %
de notre population âgée de plus de 60
ans nous sommes parmi les premiers à le
faire en union européenne
bien sûr nous avons nettement diminuer
le nombre de décès et nous espérons que
effectivement en autriche
le taux de cotinine nation va baisser
par rapport à d'autres pays européens
nous sommes dans la position assez
positive et nous espérons que
nous serons capables de lever les
restrictions et grâce à cela nous allons
développer l'économie le tourisme
puisque l'autriche
c'est un pays touristique et j'espère
que le tourisme va se développer et nous
allons de nouveau accueillir les
touristes d'autres pays notamment les
russes pour passer leurs vacances et
c'est très bien quand il y à des
rencontres
quand les gens se croisent quand ils
entretiennent le dialogue c'est très
important pour l'économie
acheter un en europe ce sont les vaccins
produits différents se fabrique un
imbécile et à 80/100 donc il n'y a pas
de monopole et l'union européenne
on doit cette monopole d'un seul
fabricant et pour autant que nous
sachions se fabrique un aucune
responsabilité pour ce vaccin en plus
les faits en touche sur lequel ce vaccin
est basé est aussi inclus il n'y a t'il
pas de risque pour l'union européenne
avec ce monopole artificielle avec la
domination d'un seul acteur je dois dire
que je suis évidemment cette situation
de près de fait plus d'un an c'est à
dire tous ces problèmes liés à la
pandémie et la question des vaccins est
tué crucial et
en europe évidemment j'ai en autriche en
particulier et le vaccin nous
l'utilisons et nous utilisons aussi
d'autres vaccins moderna et d'autres
aussi et nous allons approuver
l'utilisation d'autres vaccins encore
figé ça on peut en parler mais au sein
de l'union européenne dont nous nous
occupons de la question de faire en
sorte que la vaccination se fasse aussi
vite que possible parce que nous devons
protéger notre population est bien
entendu ces processus de suivi
comme vous l'avez dit
son complexe le vaccin foot nick v n'est
pas encore approuvé nous le regrettons
et nous serions prêts à l'acheter pour
l'autriche
mais comme je le dis nous pouvons
utiliser en autriche seulement les
vaccins qui ont été approuvées et dont
la mise en circulation a été approuvé et
j'espère que bientôt ce côté levé le
sera aussi
comme je le dis parce que comme selon la
vie aujourd'hui un 66 pays utilisent
déjà le spoutnik v j'espère que cela va
venir en l'union européenne aussi je
considère que tout vaccin qui est
efficace et sûr sera utilisé tôt ou tard
je pense qu'au niveau international
suivons la bonne voie en cours collabore
avec différentes et pour éviter des
monopôles mais vous avez raison c'est
vrai que pour l'instant il n'y a pas
encore d'autorisation de mise sur le
marché pour le spoutnik v l'europe
j'espère que cela va se faire
on a les seins politiken renom sur
lesquels le vaccin c'est une armée russe
c'est un moyen de pression
je pense que c'est une lutte qui tour de
l'argent de la part de ceux qui
produisent d'autres les préparations
similaires ils le font de façon très
très clair mais ils le font très bien
justement ils promeuvent leurs produits
sur le marché
je sais pas simplement que je lis des
titres de presse là dessus je veux pas
citer de noms mais j'ai discuté avec
avec un des dirigeants de l'union
européenne
pourquoi nous demande auprès des
organismes européens il dit non je sais
mais si mais j'ai téléphoné au likoud
mais oui mon adresse une demande déjà de
la ligue 2 l'an dernier et ce n'est
qu'en mars de cette année que la
structure jeune et concerne les routes
d'asie qu'elle commençait à la procédure
de l'examen et senna se poursuit
qu'est ce que ça signifie ça veut dire
qu'il ya des intérêts concrets de la
part de ceux qui mènent cette extrémité
ils assurent leur marché avec les
structures avec lesquelles il travaille
depuis longtemps donc un système jeux
d'intérêts croisés qui est bien
structuré je vais pas entrer dans les
détails
et tout cela est lié d'ailleurs tout ce
que vous avez dit au niveau politique
c'est ce sont des instruments
à usage commercial c'est dans différents
pays européens les institutions
différence d'ailleurs pour des
considérations politiques c'est dire que
ceux qui ont les structures nationales
qui corresponde avec des laboratoires
qui sont capables d'effectuer une
évaluation de différents produits
pharmaceutiques et puis il y en a qui
n'ont pas ces soucis et qui sont obligés
de dépendre des régulateurs autres ceux
qui en prennent les décisions
c'est le cas de la hongrie par exemple
ils ont certifié le produit chez eux et
ils utilisent bien entendu la politique
existe toujours un degré ou un autre
mais ici il s'agit clairement d'intérêt
économique aux dépens de la santé des
citoyens européens
le premier à m baptisé spoutnik
on voit cette analogie le premier en un
espace a été aussi
politique mais à l'époque tout le monde
à s'intéresser à la conquête de l'espace
maintenant les russes ne veulent pas se
faire vacciner mais pourquoi je pense
que les raisons sont nombreuses même de
la grippe même contre la grippe tout le
monde se fait pas vacciner
donc c'est dirai simplement une
disposition d'esprit chez nos citoyens
je le dis dans mon jeu d'un crédit
social
nous sommes prêts à vacciner tous ceux
qui le veulent
on va forcer personne simuler oui on va
le faire et d'ailleurs je pense qu'il
faut le faire dans beaucoup de free
propose un une
une bière contre la vaccination dans
certains produits mais on peut utiliser
des moyens plus civilisés je pense mais
ce qui est important ici s'est il
expliqué expliquer la nécessité de et la
sécurité de ce vaccin
donc il faut travailler c'est à dire en
tout cas les organes du pouvoir écrit
qu'ils doivent travailler ici oui
peut-être
oui on peut proposer un morceau de
saucisson est certain c'est votre sujet
nous allons parler de questions de
bilatérales je partirai type outils du
principe de chercher un mode de
règlement de ces de ces relations qui
sont particulièrement tendues
aujourd'hui tout le monde le sait nous
allons parler de la stabilité
stratégique du règlement des conflits à
l'international sur les points les plus
chauds du globe
nous allons parler des processus de
désarmement de lutte contre le
terrorisme de la pandémie de la lutte
contre la pandémie nous en parler aussi
de questions dog est cochée c'est en
gros l'agenda qui est prévu il y avait
plus de sens
ici il faut demander à moi qu'il faut
demander nous n'introduisons qu'une
sanction simplement là
nous considérons qu'il faut pouvoir se
protéger parfois on répond mais pourquoi
les partenaires américains agissent de
cette façon pour moi c'est toujours
assez énigmatique je suis même convaincu
qu'il s'agit en premier lieu d'un
processus politique interne aux états
unis et que les relations russo
américaines sont prises en otage dans ce
système et j'espère qu'un jour ça va
finir et que les intérêts en matière de
sécurité de stabilité stratégique de
réduction des armements qui sont
dangereux pour toute l'humanité
je pense que cela sera un plus important
que la conjoncture économique politique
interne aux états unis déclaration
déclarations contre la russie à quoi
doit-on s'attendre d'un contexte de ce
sommet les états unis je pense pas que
cela sera sous cette clé jeu
je pense que la rencontre union
européenne baden va aborder
je pense pas que la question de la
russie soit au premier plan dans cette
discussion je pense qu'il s'agit surtout
de la coopération multilatérale dans
tous les domaines renforcer cette
coopération
ça va concerner le travail de
coopération à l'international de la
façon la plus générale ça va être les
questions de climat de protection du
climat et je suis convaincu que les
états unis vont finir par reconnaître la
corde paris et apporteront leur
contribution contrôle dans la lutte
contre les changements climatiques
réduire les rejets de co2 dans l'air et
c'est ça que nous attendons et je pense
que on sait très bien d'où viennent les
émissions et de la part de la triche
nous savons très bien que nous sommes
prêts à apporter notre contribution mais
mais si nous le faisons et que les états
unis ne le font pas à ce moment là ça va
avoir des conséquences dramatiques et il
nous semble important que important que
les états unis et rencontre l'union
européenne nous avons déjà évoqué ces
c'était mais je pense qu'il faut
continuer à travailler
je pense que ça fait partie des points
que nous allons discuter et nous nous
attendons quelque chose
le 15 juin et je peux dire à propos de
cette de la rencontre russo américaines
nous sommes un petit pays neutre
traditionnellement nous avons de bonnes
relations avec les pays occidentaux
comme avec les pays orientaux
donc nous avons un regard tout à fait
positif sur ce qui peut être fait ici
entre les super puissances
ces relations sont pas toujours bonnes
et je pense que c'est important qu'ils
aient de telles réunions que des
discussions puissent avoir une bonne une
bonne base ici et nous attendons des
nous attendons les résultats de cette
discussion de cette rencontre et ensuite
concerne la rencontre bayonne et l'union
peine je pense que ça se passera
seulement les dernières années on
n'avait pas l'habitude que la russie ne
soit pas le sujet des discussions au
sommet on va voir comment ça se passe
monsieur le président parmi les
discordes entre les etats-unis et la
russie il y à la question des élections
les américains disent que la russie et
s'ingère dans les élections américaines
en russie on dit que qu'il ya des ong
américain qui agissez sur le territoire
russe
en moldavie l'ambassadeur américain est
venu voir le procureur général et le
président de la commission électorale
pourrait parler à la veillée des
élections en moldavie il ya des
technologies électorale et qui ont la
nature globale est peut-être le leur est
venue de voir comment agir dans ce dans
ce sens et peut-être avoir des règles de
jeu unique
est ce que c'est possible historiquement
oui dans la pratique c'est peu probable
vous avez parlé de ces différences n'ont
pas de divergences
ils en ont une c'est qu'ils veulent
mettre un frein à notre développement
ils le disent ouvertement tout le reste
part de cette supposition principe c'est
et les restrictions dans le domaine
économique et la volonté de d'influencé
sur les processus politiques internes à
notre pays en s'appuyant sur les forces
qu'il considère comme les leurs à
l'intérieur de la russie c'est là toute
l'histoire est bien entendu observons ce
qui se passe mais ne pratiquons pas
l'ingérence
évidemment on entend toujours ces
accusations les processus politiques les
élections
regardez yeux les élections aux états
unis eux mêmes
presque la moitié des des électeurs
considèrent que ces élections n'ont pas
été justes
ce sont des sondages qui sont menées aux
états unis eux mêmes par eux
les instituts de sondage c'est pas nous
qui l'avons inventé
qu'est-ce qu'on a inventé ici pourquoi
nous accuser c'est pas nous qui avons
déclaré ça ce sont les sondages
organisés par les américains aux états
unis donc une partie des gens étaient
pas contents quand une partie des
manifestants sont entrés au processus
était bien excuser moi je pense qu'il ya
peut-être rien de bien ici mais c'était
simplement des gens qui étaient venus
faire des ravages
il avait des revendications politiques
est ce que c'est vrai oui il ya eu 450
personnes arrêtées
donc ils sont tous ils font l'objet de
poursuites pénales
soixante dix ont été arrêtés
tout de suite 31 sont toujours prêtes
sur la base de quoi est ce que quelqu'un
nous informent mathieu n'y a aucune
information
pourtant il s'agit de politique
certains ont été accusés de choses
graves voire tentative de coup d'état
oui alors pourquoi ça bon on va pas
parler de la russie mais même en
biélorussie il ya beaucoup de problèmes
internes
nous cherchons à voir une position
neutre parce que c'est la sphère du
peuple biélorusse lui-même s'est éclairé
d'une certaine façon et aux etats unis
c'est la même chose mais l'éclairage
données est différent donc les doubles
standards deux poids deux mesures il
faut chercher à s'en débarrasser alors
si on parle de la russie
les forces de l'ordre se montre trop dur
contre certaines manifestations dans la
rue et ce qui se passe en europe
quand on tire des balles les gens qui
meurent les gens qui sont éborgné ya les
gens qui sont victimes de gaz
lacrymogènes sept ans quand j'en parle
avec mes collègues avec mes partenaires
je sais pas de nom et il nous disait
vous avez vu chez vous ce qui se passe
il s'agissait de la biélorussie oui mais
nous nous sommes des pays démocratiques
vous comprenez c'est même ridicule c'est
à dire avec des balles ont des bornes
quelqu'un mais non c'est pas grave
c'était peut-être une balle caoutchouc
démocratique mais des gens vont pas se
sentir mieux après ça donc il doit y
avoir des standards généraux qui
s'applique à tous les cas et qui sont
acceptables pour tous est-ce qu'on peut
le faire
je pense que c'est peu probable parce
que tout cela est utilisé comme
instrument dans la lutte politique mais
en tout cas il faut chercher
dia on a des blagues là dessus vous
savez on fait on fait pas mais
l'essentiel c'est qu'on président vous
savez que vous avez emprunté une voie
dangereuse
je dirais que vous savez protéger les
gens qui sont entrés au capitole
mais dans ce cas peut-être si ils auront
le soutien du président russe
ils seront bloqués peut-être dans les
résolutions je dis tout de suite je
considère j'ai dit tout de suite que je
considérais pas ça comme que bien vous
m'avez pas écouté suffisamment
attentivement deuxièmement je ne donne
pas d'évaluation d'appréciation sur cet
événement pour moi je parle
une des conséquences je me moque
complètement du fait d'être bloquées sur
les réseaux sociaux ce qui m'attend
c'est la confiance du peuple russe au
niveau où on en est à monsieur le
chancelier
est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer la
chose suivante il ya eu des
protestations de masse en biélorussie
qui ont été réprimées ac c'est vraiment
il ya eu des protestations aux états
unis et d'amérique est aussi et ces
protestations ont été réprimées durement
l'union européenne a introduit des
sanctions contre la biélorussie n'a pas
reconnu la victoire du président
biélorusse et le cachet qu'on met
l'union européenne n'a pas condamné les
actions des autorités américaines et a
reconnu le président américain
mais est-ce qu'il ya la différence
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer je
vois beaucoup de différence et
honnêtement je pense qu'on peut pas
comparer parce que d'un côté
dans le cas de la biélorussie nous
avions de bonnes relations nous avions
une bonne coopération mais j'ai
l'impression que les élections n'étaient
pas justes en particulier nous avons été
troublés par cette atterrissage forcé et
l'arrestation de deux journalistes nous
l'autriche et l'union européenne
nous ne voulons pas fermer les yeux là
dessus et nous suivons ce qui se passe
avec ce qui se passe autour de
l'opposition et nous avons introduit des
sanctions
nous estimons que la situation en
biélorussie va évoluer personne n'a la
n'a d'intérêt à déstabiliser la
situation en biélorussie mais ce qui
faut il faut assurer une démocratisation
des processus les changements doivent
intervenir dans un sens positif et ne
seront ne seront peut-être pas d'accord
sur notre appréciation de ce qui se
passe ce qui se passe en biélorussie en
tout cas est important et les mesures
que nous pouvons prendre au niveau de
l'union européenne
c'est de prendre des sanctions et cela
nous a paru
bien sûr que nous aimerions que la
situation évolue il ya des intérêts
économiques et les nôtres aussi en
biélorussie et et donc nous sommes
intéressés à une amélioration de la
situation en russie en biélorussie pour
que la biélorussie suivre la voie du
développement que la société civile se
développe que les journalistes ne soient
pas poursuivis
et il y avait il y avait d'autres
réactions qui avait été suivi aussi mais
y aller par exemple il ya eu les
répressions contre les journaux il ya eu
d'autres exemples on voit que il est
nécessaire d'éviter que ce qui est
utilisé dans un pays soit nous ne le
soit pas dans un autre pays ce qui s'est
passé dans le capital dans capitole ne
peut pas être comparé avec 6 s'est
produit en biélorussie les les
événements étaient dramatiques
c'était un coup assez durs pour la
démocratie américaine mais il fallait
assurer la sécurité la stabilité
je tiens à préciser vous avez évoqué
l'arrestation de roman protasiewicz en
biélorussie l'union européenne compte en
cette arrestation vous l'avait qualifié
de journaliste est ce que vous êtes au
courant qui la combattent yeux dans le
bataillon d'azov qui même le combat des
états unis a qualifié ce bataillon de
balai un terroriste et cette personne a
combattu à sous
l'aqua gamme et puis le terroriste je ne
sais pas il est blogueur et journaliste
si son opinion ne plaît pas à quelqu'un
et il a droit de le faire mais faire
atterrir l'avion pour qu'il atterrisse
de force
et puis interpeller les gens et on leur
force qu'il est parle ce n'est pas
normal
et si on regarde les choses de façon
objective
nous sommes un pays neutre mais par
tradition
nous avons des relations économiques
très bonne avec la biélorussie nous
avons beaucoup de contacts et de notre
point de vue il ya des limites
il faut faire la différence ceux qui
franchissent cette ligne rouge ne
doivent pas le faire hein sinon on va
réagir avec les mesures dans le sein de
l'union européenne
ce que nous faisons nos croyons que ce
n'est pas admissible et il serait très
bien dans l'avenir de ne pas accepter
ces situations il faut les éviter
pour respecter ces normes puisque
poutine le week-end dernier
vous l'avez passé avec le président
biélorusse tout d'abord je tiens vous
demander si vous partagez de cette
version concernant le hamas
vous savez je ne veux pas
donner des évaluations tout de tout ce
qui se passe aux etats-unis ou bien avec
cet avion
je ne sais pas et je suis franc est ce
que les services secrets y ont participé
bien sûr que non j'ai vu les
déclarations des autorités de l'otan
comme quoi la russie à participer
écoutez l'otan court le risque si elle
est sous arrêter de le temps dans des
déclarations pareilles puisque ce genre
là ne comprennent pas comment ça se
passe tout cela est organisée d'une
autre façon une coopération
internationale n'est pas possible
là dessus nous avons interpellé à moscou
ce qui ont planifié l'assassinât du
président biélorusse mais cela a été
fait à la demande du kgb biélorusse est
le président et le russe l'a expliqué
ils n'ont pas prévu d'opérations de
services secrets
mais ils ont eu cette information que
qu'un explosif a été placé à bord d'un
avion mais là je ne veux pas donner des
évaluations au processus politique qui
se passe en violeur et si la vérité
quelque part au milieu et il vaut mieux
de ne pas s'ingérer et donner la
possibilité aux gens de se débrouiller
quoi que l'on dise à propos du régime
qui réprime quelqu'un de toute façon les
changements dans la société vont être
opéré suite à des circonstances
objectives qui sont propres à cette
société il ne faut pas se gérer
concernant l'avion je voudrais rappeler
qu'un avion d'un des leaders d'un pays a
été à terry par force
evo morales oui c'était un chef d'état
qui était forcé de sortir de l'avion
mais c'était le cas mais pas un seul cas
pas forcément avec l'avion de ce
précédent mais là cela devient une sorte
de silence
mais on le comprend très bien tout ce
qui se passe en bio le récit cela non
seulement attire l'attention de nos
voisins mais nos voisins voudrait faire
influence eux mais il ne faut pas
s'ingérer moral et je lis
poser cette question un peu c'est une
humiliation nationale il essaie
d'oublier cette histoire ne pas s'en
souvenir parce que et ils n'ont pu rien
faire
à cet égard mais si on parle de cet
avion romane protasiewicz a été
recherché un violeur ou si c'est pour ça
qu'il a été arrêté
écoutez nous avons un auditoire hausse
est assez large
notre forum économique de saint
pétersbourg c'est un forum économique
mais vous nous bombarder des questions
politiques
moi même monsieur le chancelier
également roman protasiewicz je ne le
connais pas et je ne vais pas le
connaître qu'il est
fès quelle qu'elle soit c'est ce qu'elle
veut mais je ne parle pas de protester
vite la russie recherche des genres
aussi mais est-ce que la russie pourrait
faire atterrir un avion en provenance de
londres
par exemple si quelqu'un se trouve à
bord de cet avion par exemple de l'autre
à destination de thaïlande
je ne vous dirai pas d'accord maintenant
on revient aux questions économiques
entre la russie la vie alors ici
l'intégration économique sur laquelle
profonde
écoutez nous avons des grands échanges
commerciaux environ 30 milliards de
dollars pour la biélorussie avec la
population de 10 millions de gens
c'est un volume important c'est pourquoi
je crois que vous vous le comprenez vous
que c'est une large coopération
coopération industrielle et on va la
développer
de sorte qu'on le fait partout dans le
monde
rechercher des moyens de notre travail
qu'en juin pour que ce soit
gagnant-gagnant et nous savons tous le
potentiel pour le faire dans l'industrie
dans l'agriculture dans l'énergie là il
y a beaucoup de discussions mais
rien d'étonnant ici celui qui achète et
il veut avoir un prix intéressant est
celui qui nous vend veut avoir des
bénéfices mais on va rechercher des
solutions dans le cadre de l'union
eurasiatique dans le cadre de l'union
douanière nous avons beaucoup de projets
dans le cadre de l'énergie par exemple
d'ici 2024
nous suivons cette voie vite nous sommes
en discussion oui
un partout nous avons nous avons des
différends mais ce travail est positif
et on du résultat une autre question
économique importante le système des
impôts en russie vous avez des
entreprises que la stabilité de ce
système est des signal pour le business
mais en même temps on sait que a il y a
eu une augmentation d
impôts ces dernières années par exemple
la tva et maintenant le gouvernement
verra
prendra de nouvelles décisions
concernant les grandes entreprises leurs
impôts et on vient d'apprendre que
peut-être aller ce site et
métallurgiques devront aussi payer
d'impôts supplémentaires parce que ces
sociétés ne paie pas suffisamment
d'argent
en fait notre système fiscal est assez
stable lui que l'état est obligé de
réagir à tout ce qui se passe dans le
monde et à l'intérieur mais avoir des
mesures ciblées agir de façon délicate
pour ne pas perturber les relations
économiques à l'intérieur du pays vous
avez mentionné l'augmentation des taxes
mais on peut mentionner par exemple
l'exonération de la tva des deux
certaine paix mais eux par exemple dans
la restauration ce que j'ai évoquées il
y à la baisse il y à l'augmentation mais
en général la situation est stable
puisque la pression fiscale
tu vas être acceptable et stable dans le
pays et nos savoirs réussi à le faire
concernant le secteur métallurgique
je demande de mes collègues je les
connais très bien
s'il vous plaît régis est correctement
monsieur vélo sauf la prononcer fait
peut-être c'était ou peut-être des
paroles dures mais le fait est que nous
avons vu l'évolution de la conjoncture
du marché
il y a
et super profits sur recettes du secteur
métallurgique et bien sûr nous voulons
avoir ces recettes non seulement dans le
domaine des exportations mais aussi à
l'intérieur du pays
on le comprend mais de l'autre côté il y
à une sorte de disparités dans
l'économie pourquoi parce que il y à des
acheteurs du transport automobile nos
entreprises russes qui ont signé un
contrat ils sont prêts à payer mais le
producteur eddie qui lie à une
augmentation de 70% pourquoi parce que
il y a l'augmentation des prix et pour
le métal dans l'industrie de défense
également dans le bâtiment et j'en passe
vous savez cela concerne tous les
secteurs de l'économie et y compris
l'énergie le pétrole
il y à la hausse et des prix sur le
marché international
le blé également les prix du pain qui
sont en hausse
un grand problème l'inflation et qui est
due à ce facteur
il faut faire attention nous avons
multiples outils qui nous permettent de
réagir par exemple la politique des
taxes douanières
nous le faisons quand il s'agit des
hydrocarbures là nous avons un
algorithme qui est bien rodée pour ne
pas porter préjudice au secteur
pétrolier
il y a le rapport entre les primes audio
et les prix intérieurs et là aussi il
faut le faire on peut par exemple
signer des contrats à long terme dans
l'industrie de défense aux biens dans le
secteur de bâtiment pour lé secteur
métallurgique c'est très important ce
sont les les contrats qui sont fiables
ils sont ils ont la confiance ils ont
certains qu'ils vont vendre ses produits
alors si on signe ce contrat même pas en
premier quand du prix forfaitaire mer en
pratiquant un schéma fiable stable et
les prix stables et cela va fonctionner
on peut le faire on peut prendre en
compte cet algorithme ah non monsieur il
est temps de finir notre discussion
passionnante mais je voudrais poser la
dernière question à nous vivons dans un
monde incroyable où toutes les normes
sont détruites toutes les lois sont
éliminés nous les journalistes nous
avons toujours dit qu'on parlait même
les organisations traditionnelles comme
l'organisation internationale comme
hertz sont détruites par des sanctions
et cetera
mais selon vous quel sera le monde après
la pandémie
la configuration générale du monde
qu'est ce qu'il y aura de nouveau
monsieur le chancelier à vous la parole
j'ai tiré une seule leçon de la pandémie
à savoir nous sommes toujours devant les
défis et ce serait très bien si on
réussit à lutter ensemble contre ces
défis et de ne pas créer des nouveaux
problèmes que nous créons parfois c'est
ma proposition dans le cadre de notre
coopération pour coopérer en paix au
début de la pandémie on disait toujours
que le monde va changer après la
pandémie
le mode sera différent les gens ne vont
pas voyager ne vont pas organiser des
grands événements mais je crois qu on
voit le contraire et j'ai l'impression
que grâce au vaccin
nous avons réduit le taux de
contamination et le monde redevient
le mode normal puisque les gens veulent
dialoguer avoir des contacts et je crois
que le monde
après pandémie serait le même
on va retrouver une vie normale et il
faut que ce soit plus rapide
il faut relancer la croissance
économique
et je crois que la pandémie c'était une
grande leçon à savoir ne comprenons très
bien que la santé c'est très important
il faut être très attentif
il faut agir avec beaucoup de
précautions la pandémie la montrer à
tout le monde nous devons développer
notre économie rétablir les technologies
faire attention à la santé soulignant
avez vous quelque chose à ajouter
qu'elle votre vision du monde d'après la
pandémie
bien sûr pour le moment nous vivons dans
les conditions de la pandémie et d'un
prince et économie de beaucoup de pays
ont souffert mais dans d'autres pays
nous voyons des indices de la relance
économique et au qatar nous sommes très
fiers puisque nous avons réussi à
surmonter beaucoup de problème est dû à
cet impact de la pandémie
bien sûr nous avons accumulé une
expérience qui nous permet de gérer ces
situations d'agir très vite mais bien
sûr nous avons besoin de la coopération
internationale surtout quand il s'agit
du des nouveaux vaccins de leur
diffusion partout dans le monde et nos
voulons en finir le plus vite possible
mais je crois qu il faut avoir l'accès
au vaccin pour tous les gens là nous
avons besoin du cadre normatif
nous avons besoin du soutien de
spécialistes et d'experts hui le monde
peut changer mais je partage la mis la
vie de mon ami le chancelier fédéral de
l'autriche nous avons accumulé une
grande expérience et maintenant nous
sommes capables de gérer plus rapidement
quel sera le monde
d'abord un la pandémie nous a montré à
notos à quel point nous sommes
vulnérables
ça c'est la première chose deuxième
chose
nous avons pris conscience du rôle de
l'importance de la science était haute
technologie et de cette union d'efforts
pour surmonter les crises commune
rien qu ensemble nous pouvons obtenir
des résultats escomptés bien sûr la
pandémie a galvanisé les hautes
technologies et tout ce qui va
déterminer le progrès dans les années à
venir je parle de l'intelligence
artificielle des technologies numériques
j'en passe mais à mon avis l'essentiel
c'est que nos sommes conscients de ce
qui est la valeur majeure dans le monde
c'est la santé et la communication
humaine
il nous manquait tout cela et il nous
manque encore nous avons compris que la
santé et la communication c'est notre
valeur et principal et c'est comme ça
que nos côtes
nous devons construire notre vie
aujourd'hui et dans l'avenir
[Applaudissements]
mesdames messieurs merci de votre
attention à quelqu'un indique que le
forum économique à 35 de
saint-pétersbourg nous ressemble au 1er
septembre à l'école quand
on ne s'est pas vu depuis longtemps et
puis on s'est réunis finalement j'espère
que nous pouvons attendre plus ensemble
je voudrais vous remercier tous et avant
tout l'émir du qatar le chancelier
fédéral de l'autriche merci de
participer à notre discussion
d'aujourd'hui et je vous souhaite un
très beau succès et meilleurs voeux
merci